avec l'audition du professeur didier
raoult et de l'institut hospitalo
universitaires en maladies infectieuses
de marseille comme il se doit je vous
faisais présente les excuses d'alain
milon président de la commission et de
la commission denquête qui est retenu
sur son département
voilà rappelé que le bureau de notre
commission denquête avait initialement
conçu cette audition sur la forme de
tables rondes ainsi que je l'évoquais ce
matin alors que dans d'autres pays la
réponse à la crise a été incarné par un
personnage politique un médecin ou un
chercheur qui a réussi à entraîner la
population derrière ces recommandations
nous avons assisté en france à des
propos discordants qui ont beaucoup nui
au niveau de confiance de la population
à propos d'un virus inconnu les attentes
dans la science était très élevé certes
la controverse est normale elle fait
avancer la science
mais quand elle s'étale aussi largement
dans les médias elle fait plutôt
augmenter le niveau d'inquiétude
nous avions donc souhaité demander des
explications aux scientifiques comme
certains n'ont pas manqué de nous le
rappeler mais nous ne lire nous
n'aurions pas nous ne sommes pas des
scientifiques de haut niveau et ce n'est
pas une conversation scientifique
ce n'est pas à une conversation
scientifiques que nous convions nos
intervenants nous représentons des
personnes qui dans leur immense majorité
ne le sont pas davantage c'est pourquoi
nous aurions préféré et préférait éviter
les monologues sans contradictoires
toutefois ainsi que vous l'avez rappelé
lors de votre audition à l'assemblée
professeur à propos du conseil
scientifique
vous n'êtes pas arriver à vous parler et
il nous est apparu que vous ne
parviendrez pas davantage dans cette
enceinte à parler en toute sérénité
cette audition a pour objet la recherche
les tests et les traitements elle
abordera notamment la méthodologie
applicable aux essais cliniques
les orientations privilégiées en france
au vu de la comparaison entre discovery
et recovery
les résultats ainsi que la question des
publications ou d annonce précoce dans
la crise
donc je vais demander aux professeurs
out de présenter brièvement ses
principaux messages en 10 15 minutes
parce que les messages sont importants
et vous ne manquerez pas bien sûr de
nous alimenter par voie écrite comme
vous l'avait déjà fait à différentes
occasions je demanderai ensuite chacun
des des rapporteurs d'intervenir et
ensuite ce seront nos des questions de
nos commissaires que nous regroupons
voilà alors avant c'est une commission
denquête donc je vais procéder à la
demande de deux prêté serment rappeler
que tout propos mensongers et punis
d'une peine pouvant aller jusqu'à cinq
ans d'emprisonnement et de 75000 euros
d'amendé
donc professeur didier raoult ltte prêté
serment de dire la vérité rien que la
vérité levé la main droite et dit je le
jure je je merci bonjour appelle bien
sûr comme à chaque fois il est de mon
devoir que le port du masque est
obligatoire
je vous demande la plus grande vigilance
par le pour le garder tout au long des
heures de ses auditions de cet après
midi merci donc sans plus tarder et bien
écoutez je vous cède la parole
je vous remercie et d'ailleurs je
voudrais profiter de cette offre merci
de ma vie tu es ici de cette occasion
dans lequel vous m'avez demandé de juré
de dire toute la vérité
pour vous expliquer pourquoi je ne peux
pas me retrouver à discuter avec des
gens qui font une tribune en disant que
je frotte dès que je triche en mettant
leurs noms et ensuite faire une
discussion avec ya une limite c'est plus
des discussions scientifiques en a
d'autres qui ont porté plainte auprès de
moi auprès du conseil de l'ordre et vous
comprendrez bien que même limite c'est
une des limites à la convivialité
je n'aime pas qu'on insulte
qui n'aime pas qu'on porte plainte
contre moi a qu'à prendre demande de
débattre en toute sérénité
je le fais pas et donc je vous le dis
très solennellement et après avoir juré
de dire la vérité je n'ai jamais fraudé
de ma vie j'ai écrit 3500 publications
internationales
je n'en ai jamais rétracté aucune alors
bien entendu sur 3500 il y a eu des
erreurs qui sont passés pour l'instant
il ya une fille qui me traquent la une
chasseuse de têtes depuis que je suis
célèbre qui a réussi à trouver cinq
erreurs sur 3500 il y en a probablement
beaucoup plus que ça j'estime qu'il ya
entre 2 et 4 % d'erreurs dans les
papiers que j'ai fait et donc je ne
serais pas étonné qu'on trouve d'autres
erreurs mais je dois vous dire que je ne
suis qu'un pauvre humain que je fais des
erreurs comme tout le monde mais de
m'accuser sur une tribune officiellement
de fraude de mettre son nom là dessus et
et de penser que je vais débattre avec
c'est au dessus de mes forces et je vous
demande de me pardonner de ne pas avoir
la force de discuter sereinement avec
des gens qui m'insultent je ferai pas je
ferai jamais bien si vous si j'ai
quelques messages à passer dans cette
affaire c'est effectivement si vous
voulez la chose qui me frappe le plus
depuis le début et qui est
lié au fait qu'il manque quelque chose
dans mon la forme de mon cerveau je suis
absolument incapable de mesurer la
dimension symbolique des choses c'est
pas ce qui s'est passé n'est pas normal
c'est on n'est plus en train de parler
de chimie ou de malades ou de
médicaments on est en train de parler de
quelque chose qui qui est déconnecté de
ce que moi je connais moi je suis un
être très pragmatique et pratique il ya
toujours eu dans la science une grande
différence entre l'empirisme d'un côté
c'est à dire l'observation des
phénomènes et leur description si vous
voulez et d'autre part les théories
déductive et spéculative donc donc dont
je ne suis pas un praticien d'accord
mais si vous voulez ce qui s'est passé
dans cette situation est absolument
inouïe pour moi et pas que pour moi ça
marquera tout l'épistémologie d'histoire
des sciences
c'est à dire que un des deux médicaments
les plus prescrits au monde et qu est
considéré comme étant un truc qui tue et
10 % des gens est quelque chose qui
montre qu'il y avait une déconnexion
entre la perception de ce qui est
l'hydrochlorothiazide si vous voulez du
de la chimie de la molécule qui a été
utilisée c'est probablement deux
milliards de personnes
donc il y a quelque chose que je ne
comprends pas auquel je ne suis pas si
c'est pas de maintenant je me rends
compte que je ne comprends pas bien les
données symbolique si vous voulez c'est
comme ça et donc je suis
extraordinairement surprise l'ampleur
qu'a pris cette chose est immédiatement
c'est à dire dès que mon premier papier
a été envoyée la chasseuse de têtes l'a
fait dire que j'avais des conflits
d'intérêts avec sanofi ce qui est
complètement idiot je fais des essais
thérapeutiques pour personne ça fait 25
ans que je suis contre je fais pas la
deuxième chose est la demande
elle a fait de confirmer elle nous a
fait faire envoyer au journal qui
menaçaient de l'enlever cet article qui
est devenu le plus cité de toute la
littérature soit la thérapeutique du
coït 19,7 is it est de 1400 fois en dix
ans que je n'avais pas eu les
autorisations j'ai pas eu de cdp et la
troisième chose
un déluge des gens qui sont des
maniaques de méthodologie je ne pouvais
pas imaginer qu'en envoyant un papier
comme ça comme j'en ai envoyé tellement
dans ma vie c'est vrai ceux ci allaient
faire une espèce de folie mondiale ces
relais et donc toutes les explications
qu'on pourra donner ce sont pas
inintéressantes c'est le temps qui
triera pour comprendre ce qui se passe
moi personnellement je ne comprends pas
ça ne fait pas partie de ce que je suis
capable de comprendre parce que qui me
manque une case sur la signification
symbolique des choses peut-être pas que
symbolique
en tout cas c'est pas mon problème donc
nous on a continué à faire je pensais
depuis longtemps
en réalité depuis plus de vingt ans je
pensais qu'il fallait faire comme pour
les centres anticancéreux des centres de
lutte pour les maladies infectieuses qui
comprenait tous les patients le
laboratoire la recherche
petit à petit je les écris à 20 ans
quand j'étais le conseiller de de mattei
et de madame haigneré où j'ai rencontré
d'ailleurs gilles bloch donc qu'ils
connaissent et parfaitement mes projets
puisqu'il n'est entré au cabinet de
maintenant les directeurs dincer il
était rentré au cabinet mal amélioré en
dix ans pour faire face à des situations
comme celle-là il faut avoir des
structures organisées dans lequel on
fasse tout dentelle y ait des gens qui
soient compétents à tous les domaines et
à tous les niveaux de manière à pouvoir
répondre à toutes les questions au fur à
mesure et pas avoir un ordre dispersé
donc l' ordre dispersé sur le sénateur
je savais qu'il allait arriver
c'est pas moi qui les disperser nous
étions en ordre dispersé et d'une
manière très singulière pour pas que
vous croyez que je considère qu'à paris
plus rien n'est organisé c'est pas vrai
en neurologie si quelqu'un avait un
problème dans ma famille je l'enverrai
la pitié parce qu'il ya un centre de
neurologie qui est colossal
s'il y avait quelqu'un qui avait un
problème génétique que je l'enverrai
sûrement à necker et imagine pas de
problème avec ça mais en maladies
infectieuses
ici on a détruit l'organisation des
maladies infectieuses
elle n'existe plus et donc si vous
retrouvez avec un pauvre marseillais en
train de vous dire ce qu'ils pensent
c'est parce qu'il ya une destruction
physique de l'organisation des maladies
infectieuses qui était à l'hôpital
claude bernard
là les forces de maladies infectieuses
l'institut de veille sanitaire a été mis
à saint maurice alors que c'était une
vraie bonne idée moi j'avais écrit à
l'époque de le mettre à côté de pasteur
ou de maître - des antennes de pasteur à
côté voyez le les hôpitaux de masques
spécialement maladies infectieuses ont
été dispersées dans toute la ville et
donc vous n'avez pas de cendres vous
n'avez pas de pardonnez moi je vis vous
n'avez pas de patron et si de maladies
infectieuses vous l'avez pas alors que
vous l'aviez ya 30 ans vous l'avez pas
vous avez des patrons dans les autres
domaines vous avez des gens qui sont des
leaders dans les autres domaines dans ce
domaine là vous n'avez pas de leader
vous n'avez plus de leaders
microbiologie celui qui était le
meilleur a été tellement dégoûté séance
publique il est parti en suisse
d'accord donc vous avez il ya un
problème ici avec les maladies
infectieuses
un véritable problème d'évolution l'asie
placer qui fait des choses absolument
remarquable s'est éloigné et petit à
petit avec le temps de la pratique les
maladies infectieuses de l'hôpital
pasteur donc quand j'étais jeune on
faisait tous les diagnostics l'institut
pasteur l'épidémiologie partout à la
sécu passerelle petit à petit cette
partie là a disparu pour être remplacé
par parent une recherche fondamentale
beaucoup en neurosciences sont parmi les
meilleurs du monde
donc je vais pas une critique de la
qualité de ce qui se passe il ya une
désorganisation et une désorganisation
de ce pays et qui se voit ici pour ce
sujet je dis pas que c'est vrai pour
d'autres
si je trouve que bull pour la
microchirurgie je pense que j'en
strasbourg sont le meilleur ce que je
pense mais globalement c'est ce que je
perçois j'ai toujours pensé que j'ai pas
la chirurgie cardiaque à paris et
merveilleuse et elle continue à la
georges pompidou
c'est pas il ya un problème
d'organisation de fonds et celui des
maladies infectieuses vous savez que de
gaulle avait répondu à la cancérologie
en disant écoutez on va faire des
centres anticancéreux dont qui regroupe
à la fois la radiothérapie la
chimiothérapie la chirurgie la médecine
il marche de manière inégale mais ils
ont joué un rôle très important
là aussi en cancérologie l'institut
gustave roussy est une chose
extraordinaire ça les meilleurs centres
au monde dit
et quand c'est logique c'est pas la
question la question c'est que ce
domaine n'est pas organisé et que donc
il ne peut connaître des discordances
moi j'ai proposé de faire créer cette
centre de la nature de celui que j'ai
fini par réussir à construire à
marseille dans pays de manière à mailler
le pays pour pouvoir faire face à des
crises sanitaires qui n'arrêteront pas
et notre susceptibilité dans notre
civilisation aux crises sanitaires est
très très importante très très vive elle
peut désorganiser complètement la
société si nous ne sommes pas armés pour
lutter contre ces cellules sanitaire
voilà donc le sens général parce que je
voulais dire et puis ensuite on rentre
dans le détail de ce que vous voudrez t
merci pour cette représentation de
l'infectiologie en france donc nous
allons rentrer dans le vif du sujet je
passe parole à catherine des roches
merci monsieur le président pensait pas
que les questions agressives
j'en fais tomber mon chevalet
donc merci au professeur raoul de nous
avoir déjà donné des réponses à nos
questions très en amont pour nous les
rapporteurs de de cette audition ce qui
a permis de de travail et les réponses
et est aussi de pouvoir compléter
puisqu'on avait fait une audition dans
le cadre des commissions des affaires
sociales que je pilotais comme
rapporteur de la branche maladie ou vous
avez entendu des gens n'ont pas en
public mais où nous avions déjà balayé
un peu déçu j'aime qui correspondait
l'état de la situation au moins deux ans
au mois de mai quand nous l'avions nous
l'avions fait moi j'avais plusieurs
questions la première que plus d'ordre
pratico pratique c'est celle du parcours
du patient
qu'est-ce qui depuis le début de la
l'évolution de l'épidémie comment
est-elle parcours du patient en février
ou au début vous avez vu arriver les
premiers patients dans votre institut
quelle est-elle parcours du patient tess
de traitement isolement est-ce qu'il
s'est modifiée au fil du temps et
qu'elle est aujourd'hui le parcours d'un
patient qui vient qui vient vous
consulté à l'institut un institut
marseillais le deuxième point c'est
c'est quelque chose que j'ai posée
déjà ce matin au professeur delfraissy
même si luis nenê venu en fonction que
le 11 mars mais lorsque fin janvier la
ministre de la santé nous dit au vu de
vraisemblablement de modélisation de
l'inserm
il ya peu de risque que le virus arrive
arrive chez nous bon professeur de
français nous a dit qu'à l'époque il
s'intéresse à mon sujet mais que en
effet dès la mi-février lui même avait
avait senti quelque chose se passait
quel est votre avis sur cette ces
modélisations qu'on peut faire dire cela
la ministre de la santé de l'époque
comment l'inserm a travaillé pour
arriver à ces conclusions si ce sont ces
conclusions qui ont été à l'origine de
de la vie et vous comment au niveau de
votre institut et de votre habitude de
ces maladies infectieuses même si là on
était sur un nouveau virus vous quels
étaient les alertes que vous aviez sur
quoi vous basez pour pour avoir
à voir ce degré de connaissance
qu'apparemment les autorités n'avaient
pas ça c'est le premier point
la deuxième question c'est sur les les
essais cliniques
c'est une question que j'ai évoqué ce
matin avec le professeur delfraissy
également ces thèmes dans ces périodes
de crise sanitaire ou où les équipes
soignantes voit arriver des patients bon
pour certains en consultation mais pour
d'autres en réanimation ou en
hospitalisation et où il ya ce besoin
d'apporter une réponse rapide et
thérapeutique aux malades
comment que ça peut se concilier avec
cette exigence d'essais randomisés de
travaux scientifiques robuste pour voir
l'efficacité du traitement
mais s'il n'y a pas pour tous ces
patients qui ne rentreraient pas dans
les études ou dans les essais avec un
médicament testé
est-ce qu'il ya pas une perte de chance
pour tous ceux qui ne rentrent pas
danser dans ces cases là bon vous nous
avez dans la note
donnez votre avis un peu sur ces essais
les essais randomisés tels qu'ils sont
et pas forcément adapté à la situation
pandémique telle qu'elle était donc
j'aimerais aussi vous entendre dessus
puis une question plus que plus large
qui est peut-être pas celles centrées
sur la commission denquête mais qui nous
intéresse au sein de la commission des
affaires sociales puisqu'on avait fait
un rapport sur l'accès à l'innovation et
notamment sur les essais cliniques
les comités de protection des personnes
et j'aimerais avoir votre façon assez
rapide
votre avis en effet ce que vous nous
avez dit un peu dans la note mais
résumer sur comment vous voyez-vous les
comités de protection des personnes qui
étaient au départ de protée des comités
de protection des personnes éthiques
et qu'est ce qui a pu faire que là on
est allé assez vite sur certains essais
et que et qu'habituellement on n'y
arrive pas merci vous répondait
directement professeur à chacun chacune
des rapporteurs sur le bouton rouge pas
la solitude la manière dont nous
travaillons
comme je voulais dit je ne suis pas un
homme de spéculations donc je suis très
empirique est très pratique pragmatique
c'est la nature je me réserve de très
bonnes surprises je serais content de ce
qu'on a pu trouver je pense que l'on
peut découvrir d'ailleurs que par
l'observation et l'empirisme où on peut
confirmer par les techniques
méthodologiques mais on peut pas
découvrir ça fait l'objet de grands
grands débats épistémologiques donc la
manière dont nous travaillons d'abord
c'est que nous lisons toute la
littérature et donc si vous voulez moi
j'ai été frappée du fait si vous voyez
le staff que nous avons donc il ya une
vingtaine de gens qui sont au niveau
professeurs ou juste en dessous qui
travaillons ensemble chacun avec
beaucoup de domaines c'est pour ça que
je crois à ce que j'appelle l'ennemi de
recherche et non pas au réseau je crois
au nil recherche et on se voit tous les
jours tous les jours tous les jours à 8
heures du matin et on a un pharmacien
qui nous fait donc vous avez vu vous
voyez les applications de la mm qu'est
ce qui est vraiment est ce que vraiment
on applique là et même quand on est
médecin et la réponse c'est non
deuxièmement on a une spécialiste
d'hématologie co régulation qui fait la
bibliographie des de stomatologie
coagulation on a un super immunologiste
qui était un ancien directeur des
sciences de la vie du cnrs qui fouillent
vraiment au niveau moléculaire sur la
physiopathologie d'un chimiste
bien sûr on a des infectiologues
virologues microbiologiste et chacun
nous des épidémiologistes de très très
haut niveau dont celui qui a fait toutes
les enquêtes sont charles de gaulle dont
je reparlerai qui font un travail de
fond sur le suivi permanent de la
biographie sur ces domaines et à chaque
fois qu'on a une question quelqu'un
creuse comme un fou pour en tirer
quelque chose
ce qui veut dire je vous en ai déjà dit
ce qu'on a déjà fait 54 publications
internationales qui sont ou publiez vous
acceptez ou en prêt print donc quand on
s'est retrouvé face à la situation on a
fait comme d'habitude c'est à dire qu'on
a lu tout ce qu'avait fait les seuls
sachant qu'ils étaient chinois et on a
regardé
qu'est ce qu'ils font et qu'est ce qu'il
et puis on a regardé qu'est ce qui se
passe avec les autres coronavirus et
qu'est ce qui s'est passé avec le
premier épisode de sa au début moi je
vous assure j'ai téléphoné tout de suite
au ministère pour dire écoutez voilà les
médicaments qui marche sur le cervin
pourquoi regarde pas le cargo side qui
est anti staphylococcique qui est
générique et qui coûtent rien qui a été
utilisé dans le sahara un en corée qui a
même eu un brevet un moment qui a été
déposé pour le traitement du sahara avec
ça deuxièmement la chloroquine qui avait
été montée je rappelle que fossiles un
nom revient en arrière mais à l'époque
il est le traitement du sahara et donc
les premiers résultats qui sont venues
de chine
in vitro a publié nordin un des articles
du groupe de journaux celles ci sont
très bons journaux c'était écouter les
deux médicaments qui marche la
chloroquine et grossit chloroquine d'une
part et d'autre part leur m10 sévir et
lui n'étaient pas disponibles sauf à
avoir des accords avec gilead ou à
travailler sur des essais dans le cadre
de ce que voulait faire gilad que nous
voulions pas faire donc nous peu de
temps après les chinois ont commencé à
dire écoutez on a de manière
préliminaire nos premiers résultats il
ya 100 malades qu'on a traitées on voit
une amélioration clinique radiologique
et sur le portage virale c'est ça qu'on
a fait c'est à dire qu'on si vous voulez
le lead et on vous dira ce risque de
sainte émélie dès que les choses vont se
dérouler en france ces cds qui n'a pas
lieu
c'est une pandémie ça se déroule partout
il ya tout le monde a une expérience
tout le monde a quelque chose à dire et
donc on doit regarder les premiers qui
ont subi le flux pour voir déjà il avait
décrit une quantité de choses dont nous
y compris des choses qu'on a découvert
un peu plus tardivement comme ce que ce
qu'ils appelaient les l'hypoxie heureuse
voulait c'est-à-dire le fait qu' il n'y
avait pas les signes respiratoires qu'on
a d'habitude dans les pneumonies et donc
ça c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose c'est que dès qu'on a
eu des cas on s'est mis à l' d'abord
tout de suite et je réponds à quelqu'un
qui me demander pourquoi il ya une telle
un tel délai dans la mise en place des
tests nous les tests dès que le génome a
été publié trois jours appelés à en
commander les amorces pc donc l'idée une
des raisons du retard c'est qu'il y
avait ce que j'ai eu l'occasion
d'expliquer assemblée nationale c'est
qu'il y avait dans l'esprit des gens du
ministère qu'il y avait des centres
nationaux de référence quitte ce qui est
un rêve parce qu'il peut pas y avoir un
centre national de référence pour 2010
qui n'existe pas c'est pas possible pas
de centres nationaux de référence et des
gens qu'ils et moi je suis plus money
les gens qui faisaient les coronavirus
c'est pas du tout d'ailleurs c'est
quelqu'un qui est à caen d'accord donc
c'est les gens se sont dit mais c'est
nous les centres nationaux de référence
est donc au début ces discussions me
disait écouter non mais il faut les cas
positifs faut que vous les envoyer au
centre national de référence mais tout
le monde avec des séquences à sont là on
avait le génome qui avait publié chinois
trois jours après nous on avait commandé
les les allemandes qui va extrêmement
vite et brillantissime hambourg à a tout
de suite dit que tu es voilà moi j'ai
testé une pub pcr donc on avait nous
sélectionné trois gènes qu'on avait
commandé pour qu'elle en avait commandé
les témoins positif de on a commandé les
2,2 des allemands et puis ensuite quand
pasteur a présenté un budget sain on
april et c'est en a pris tout ce qui
existe et puis on va tester on a regardé
ce qui est bien d'ailleurs pas ce que tu
entends avec la paix certes peut-être
une question qui reviendra parfois il ya
des contaminations qui soit un pca il
faut toujours avoir une deuxième cache
est une troisième pour être sûr de
confirmer les cas qui sont positifs pour
pas raconter des choses qui sont fausses
parce que il n'ya pas de laboratoire
dans lequel ça n'arrive pas qu'il ya une
contamination
c'est pas vrai plaisir c'est comme ça
donc si vous voulez le la manière dont
nous avons réagi nous c'est on regarde
ce que fait tout le monde on fait je
m'excuse de cet anglicisme du match
marking c'est à dire qu'on regarde ce
qu'ils savent faire
on fait pareil en les imitent mais c'est
comme ça que la séance avance de neuf
fois sur dix passe dans 10 à imiter ceux
qui ont eu la première expérience on
fait pareil et donc on a au début on a
fait pareil très rapidement très
rapidement on a vu qu'on n'était pas sur
la même longueur d'onde parce que chaque
fois qu'on parlait de cette maladie on
nous parlait décès
et de et de cpp d'en savoir s'il fallait
les gens qui étaient contagieux leurs
maîtres alors faire un prélèvement
rhinopharyngé on tombait des nues
qu'est ce que vous nous raconter c'est
les gens ils sont revenus pour savoir si
j'avais ça on va pas la faire signer un
tapez leur disons qu'ils sont d'accord
pour qu'on les tests pour savoir s'ils
ont le virus
soyez donc on n'était pas ben depuis le
début on n'est pas branché sur la même
voie il ya quelque chose qui m'échappe
je suis pas branché c'était et donc je
les voyais pas comme des sujets d'essai
vous le dit gilles premières et donc je
les vois toujours pas comme des sujets
décès et j'ai suivi au fur et à mesure
qu'il y avait des données qui arrive et
on les a suivis
le premier patient qu'on a eu le
deuxième arrêté c'est sa femme qui était
la première belle le premier patient
qu'on a eu et était quelqu'un qui qui
nous a qui nous a parlé de son anneau
demi si vous voulez traiter un sujet sur
lequel ont travaillé pour essayer
d'identifier quelles étaient les causes
d'infections respiratoires y ait entre
un virus qui est par l'influencé 3 qui
donne des anneaux semis au printemps la
noce missionnaire c'est par un flanc et
trois donc ça nous intéresse
la note b donc on a repéré la noémie
mais si vous ne la cherchez pas et
maintenant on sait qu'il ya 60% des gens
mais les gens n'ont pas observé ça donc
cette phase d'observations empiriques et
de lecture de la delà de la littérature
vous voyez bien que dans les faits
discovery afin de pardon recovery des
anglais je dis pas du mal de français
ils n'ont pas mis ce critère clinique en
disant on peut faire du diagnostic
clinique d'une maladie avec ce qui est
parfait il faut faire des tests
biologiques et donc ils ont publié ça
donc il ya quand même des gens qui ont
publié des séries qui servent
actuellement à réfléchir chez des gens
qui n'ont pas eu de confirmation
diagnostic et même l'élément clinique le
plus déterminant de tous il le
connaissait pas qui était la nauze me
aggasy d'accord qui a été connue
ultérieurement et nous je vous assure
vous fait un tri avec la noce mis en
musique il était incroyablement
fonctionnel ça marche très très bien on
l'a testé après en particulier en a
testé dans le dans le personnel de soins
si vous voulez et là on a pu les
interroger avant de savoir s'il avait
été contaminée pas donc il ya une vraie
comprend
ça part très très bien pour les gens
quant au moins de 60 ans et un test
merveilleux de d'efficacité donc voilà
ce qu'on a fait et au fur à mesure que
le savoir s'est accumulée bien entendu
on a changé
on s'est rendu compte au bout d'un
certain moment qui avait pas ce que
c'était mal décrit au départ qu'il y ait
des troubles de la coagulation très
important on a commencé c'est d'abord
les réanimateurs qui n'ont vu puis
ensuite nous on s'est rapidement mis à
anti coaguler les gens quand on s'est
rendu compte que les marqueurs de la
coagulation étaient des marqueurs de
pronostic est extrêmement important
après il ya eu les premiers travaux qui
sont sortis de chine encore sur les
autopsies qui montrait que ce qu'on
prenait souvent pour des vidéos peut ne
pas être des pneumonies en réalité
c'était embolie pulmonaire multiples et
que c'était des lésions d'infarctus du
poumon et non pas de pneumonie ce que
l'on voyait les chinois avaient publié
aussi qu'il fallait faire des scanners
low dose sur lequel je me suis déjà
prononcé je pense qu'on a beaucoup de
retard
ça fait partie des projets de nouveaux
gouvernements de d'acheter d'augmenter
de l'équipement on a besoin de plus
beaucoup plus de scanner un
sous-équipement absolument terrible dans
ce pays de scanners pour remplacer les
radios thorax par les scanners low dose
à terme les chinois avaient publié que
il y avait au moins la moitié des gens
qui étaient dix à symptomatique ce qui
est une erreur c'est à dire sans fil et
nick identifiable en particulier
respiratoires
si vous voulez qu'il y avait des lésions
pulmonaires au scanner on a confirmé sa
d'accord donc ça veut dire bien sûr la
prise en charge à 100 arrêt changé
puisque quand vous avez des gens qui dit
est-ce qu'il faut tester les gens
asymptomatiques mais asymptomatiques
savent de quel point de vue est ce que
ca symptomatique que parce que vous les
chambres sont pas essoufflé apparemment
ou est ce que vous regardez la
saturation en oxygène ce qu'on fait
systématiquement est ce que vous
regardez les scanners et donc vous ne
voyez pas la même chose bien entendu de
la manière dont vous regardez les gens
va pas vous dire donc si vous les
considérez comme la grippe
si vous voulez donc la déduction en fait
c'est comme la grippe c'est pas vrai
c'était une autre maladie et pour le
savoir il faut prendre le temps il faut
les regarder quand il faut commencer en
les examinant regarde regarde ce qui se
passe on regarde les examens
lille a dit littérature de ceux qui en
avaient déjà eu 5000 cas comme ça nous
est arrivé dessus d'accord et à partir
de ça on définit une stratégie pas avant
en tout cas moi c'est ce que nous on a
pensé c'est ce que l'on a fait voilà
ultérieurement effectivement quand on a
vu cette situation nous on a décidé
qu'il fallait puisque nous ne savions
pas qui c'est qui allait avoir des
lésions et pas des lésions comme ça
avait été décrit en chine avant que ça
commence en france à eh bien on a décidé
qu'on a dit il faut tester les gens
quand ils viennent d'accord et on a
commencé à tester les gens quand ils
venaient
on a tout de suite mis en place notre
système de pcr à très haut débit parce
que vous savez que les français ont été
rapatriés du yuan juste à côté de chez
nous et donc très rapidement on a
commencé à tester des centaines de des
centaines de pcr et donc on a on a fait
ça voilà et donc au fur et à mesure et
bien on a augmenté 1
maintenant on a et on conseille aux gens
de mesurer leur saturation en oxygène
s'ils ont moins de 80 cas je pense qu'il
faut que généraliser show qui viennent
un hôpital pour allant de l'oxygène
parce que sinon au moment où ils sentent
qu'ils sont à l'instant respiratoire
c'est juste avant de rentrer en réa et
même maintenant il ya même un marseille
il ya entre 50 et 60% des gens qui
rentrent en réanimation qui commencent
leurs soins en réanimation et cela on
aurait peut-être pu empêcher qu'ils
rentrent en réanimation les oxygen en
avant les anticoagulants avant voyez
donc c'est une notion qui est importante
qu'on pouvait pas connaître avant cette
discordance si vous voulez entre les
signes cliniques et l'état d'oxygénation
est d'ailleurs un de ceux qui est bon
pas mais plus jeunes 59 ans est mort
d'embolie pulmonaire
s'il était arrivé trois semaines plus
tard et c'est à mort parce qu'on savait
à ce moment là trois semaines plus tard
donc cette connaissance progressive si
vous voulez va mal avec des opinions
très tranchées initial et puis donc au
fur et à mesure du savoir nous avons
modifié les choses comme je voulais dire
on a fait on a proposé tout de suite
hein
une proposition des ces thérapeutiques
limitées ce qui avait été fait en chine
avec des posologies
avec lesquels les familiers l'hydroxyte
le rookie et glaner ces thérapeutiques
qui a toujours été avec un seul bras
donc a été validé par le cpp à l'époque
on a rajouté parce que c'est ça fait
partie de la pratique clinique de l'asie
trop missiles dont on savait par
ailleurs que c'était un antiviral soit
des virus à arn et on a eu la surprise
de voir que les charges virales diminué
à une vitesse absolument spectaculaire
donc on a dit mais voilà a prévenu mais
tout de suite on a toujours tenu au
courant le ministère et on a voulu faire
un essai thérapeutique en disant écoutez
cette azithromycine c'est tellement
impressionnant qu'on veut faire un
groupe hydroxy chloroquine un groupe
l'hydroxyte leur routine azithromycine
et là dans le cpp on est tombé sur la
méthodologie ce qu'ils voulaient qu'on
reparte à zéro et qu'on fasse un groupe
de placebo ce que moi je pouvais pas
faire parce que je considère que ce
n'est pas éthique
bonjour et parfaire et donc on l'a dit
et on va faire ce que le soins courants
et de l'état de la connaissance nous
permet de dire ce qu'on est publié donc
c'est ce qu'on a fait et donc ensuite
bien au fur et à mesure on a continué à
avoir une politique de cette nature
compte tenu du fait que les gens ont
soulevé quelque chose qui m'étonne sur
ce qui m'étonne toujours d'ailleurs sur
le sur la toxicité potentielle de
l'hydroxyde brooklyn on a rajouté pour
pour être sûr qu'il y avait aucun
problème on a demandé au professeur de
cardiologie de vérifier to know to know
électrocardiogramme
on a fait systématiquement des cas lié
ni à tout le monde pour être sûr et on a
installé dans les hacher la dosage de
potassium en moins d'une demi-heure pour
être sûr de pouvoir tout de suite dont
le traitement donc tout ça au fur à
mesure que les questions sont levés on a
réagi pragmatiquement parce qu'on a
cette autonomie cette capacité à faire
les choses sur place et décider au fur
et à mesure de les faire fonctionner et
puis voilà maintenant
soit les gens comme ça et puis je vous
ai donné tous ces chiffres sont
entièrement officiel aussi les chiffres
que je vous donne je peux pas inventer
chiche je donne tout ça tous les jours à
la rs tous les morts tous les détecter
tous les positifs on peut pas inventer
des chiffres dans ce pays c'est c'est
l'assistance publique va c'est pas peut
pas inventer les chiffres c'est donc
faut revenir sur terre gens qui pensent
qu'on invente les données mais je sais
pas si ça va tourner un pays administrés
parfois trop opportuniste soucoupe parce
que il y aura beaucoup de questions
catherine des roches avait posé la
question sur les cpp éthiques
oui moi je si vous voulez un avis j'ai
un avis qui est qui est le mien est donc
que je veux bien partager vous savez je
me méfie peut-être parce que le temps a
passé je me méfie beaucoup de toutes les
modes
donc je suis pas très sensible non plus
à ça les modes méthodologique ce sont
des modes méthodologique
c'est je vais vous donner un exemple je
voulais donner parce que vous n'êtes pas
obligés de me croire mais je vous donne
les documents sur lequel on va arriver
ce document je lui ai transmis le
cochrane library sont spécialisés
peut-être 25 ans pour analyser toutes
les publications et toutes les
recommandations d'accord et comme
maintenant les recommandations depuis
qu'il a été développé quelque chose qui
s'appelle la médecine basée sur les
évidences et de dire écoutez il faut
avoir un essai ou deux essais randomisés
donc là dessus ils ont étudié et eux
c'est les rois de cette analyse là et
eux ils ont analysé 250 méta analyse des
analyses qui a regroupé plusieurs années
donc plus de 4000 analyse pour regarder
s'il y avait une différence de résultats
de qualité entre les études randomisées
les études observationnelles et la
conclusion c'est qu'il n'ya pas de
différence
d'accord donc le fait que les études
randomisées et soit l'alpha et l'oméga
de la prise en charge thérapeutique
c'est juste par canton recommandations
aussi parce que vous non
moi c'est les choses qui pour moi les
deux fois mais s'il faut que j'explique
jeu les explique
moi j'ai regardé les recommandations de
société américaine de maladies
infectieuses je vous ai donné la
référence avec quelqu'un qui a fait une
fois cette analyse en disant combien des
recommandations société américaine de
maladies infectieuses sont basés sur au
moins une étude randomisée à 18% donc à
81 2% des recommandations thérapeutiques
en maladies infectieuses aux états unis
pour lequel il y à zéro et une en
devises est d'accord donc il faut être
un peu plus paisible avec sa avant de
dire vous savez c'est la règle et comme
ça sinon vous tuer c'est nous qui savons
ça et c'est de l'idéologie c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles je ne veux pas
discuter de ça sur le plan idéologique
je les fais déjà j'avais fait jeudi déjà
chuté online où j'avais invité
costagliola pour parler des méthodes
nous n'étions pas d'accord parce que sur
le plan idéologique nous ne sommes pas
d'accord
maintenant nous ne sommes pas d'accord
non plus j'ai essayé de l'exprimer comme
médecin moi je ne veux pas faire ça sert
je ne peux pas à dire un malade
écoutez je vais vous donner un truc je
sais pas si un traitement ou pas dedans
et je vous tire au sort je sais pas le
faire
je n'ai jamais su le faire et je ne le
ferai pas et les malades qui accepte je
vous assure que 1 soit ils n'ont pas
compris soit la plupart refusent parce
qu'on n'est pas là pour ça d'accord et
donc il ya une vraie question qui est
est ce que on devient manière que du
méthode si vous voulez qui manifestement
n'est pas réellement pratiqué très
fréquemment par des praticiens d'accord
ou est ce que on est dans le contrat
millénaire que nous avons deux je vais
faire du mieux que je peux avec ce que
je sais où ce que je crois savoir à ce
moment là pour vous spécifiquement et
donc il ya une vraie question et on a vu
pour revenir sur la question précisément
pour les cpp une dérive qui s'est faite
au début les cpp c'était fait pour ça
c'était fait pour attendez vous n'avez
pas faire l'expérience avec n'importe
quoi donc il faut qu'il est sage qui
regardait donc il est prévu des
compositions de ses pétages parce que
rappelle ses anciens jeux parce que moi
je les ai vus naître le le dedans il
était prévu qu'ils aient des gens de
sagesse dedans donc il fallait qu'ils
aiment
être un pasteur un rabbin des gens qui
aient la sagesse et le recul pour dire
écoutez faut faire attention est ce que
c'est nécessaire moi je peux vous dire
j'ai créé dans cette dans ce pays le
premier comité d'éthique animal en
france d'accord c'est vrai qu'on a eu
des problèmes terribles faculté de
médecine j'étais en charge de la
recherche
je vous parle de 1989 et on a fait un
comité d'éthique pour dire écoutez
est-ce que ce truc est vraiment
nécessaire est ce que c'est d'avoir les
conditions de vie évidemment
est-ce que c'est pas totalement inutile
donc les cpp c'est à ça que ça sert les
cpp ça sert à dans notre comité
d'éthique animal et on avait interdit
les essais sur les chiens des chats et
les sages ce qui simplifiait les
rapports avec la population environnante
les rongeurs donc il y a une vraie
question c'est les cpp s'est pas fait
s'il ya une prise de pouvoir par les
météorologistes c'est pas fait pour
valider la méthodologie c'est pour
savoir si ces mots rares
c'est ça que ça veut dire est ce que on
a le droit de faire ça dans cette
situation là et donc cette des lives la
deux oui on a le droit de faire ça dans
cette situation là vous avez le droit de
faire de l'expérimentation dans cette
situation là es tu devenu une dérive
administrativo méthodologique qui n'a
plus rien à voir avec la raison pour
laquelle ça a été créée donc c'est pour
ça que je pense qu'effectivement il faut
s'emparer
j'espère enfin moi je pense que le
législateur doit s'emparer de cette
question de cette réflexion sur
l'expérimentation humaine en sachant
écouter la l'histoire de nous faire
avoir un scpp pour d'autres pour faire
un écouvillon farrage et je pense que
c'est du délire voyez je pensais pas ça
mieux et je pense que deux en revanche
de faire des essais grande folie quand
les essais de non-infériorité et c'est
une en infériorité c'est de dire aux
gens je passe en qui on peut faire
accepter de dire à jean on va tester un
médicament pour savoir s'il est aussi
bon que le traitement de référence qui
c'est qui peut faire ça qu'ils aient
quelques et la personne qui va accepter
une chose pareille ça il ya dizaine
d'essais de l'infériorité qui sont faits
tous les nouveaux médicaments ils sont
faits avec des essais de non-infériorité
parce qu'ils sont pas meilleurs que les
autres c'est pas vrai on n'arrive pas à
le démontrer donc si vous voulez il ya
une vraie réflexion de fond avoir moral
je pense qui est aussi un des éléments
probablement qui a fait jaillir une
telle
une telle un tel conflit c'était votre
deuxième question
voilà je crois que vous avez répondu aux
questions catherine oui s'il entend bien
le parcours du patient qui arrive chez
vous est le même depuis depuis le hall
est améliorée sans les fois une
amélioration
si vous voulez où on a acheté du coup
quand on s'est rendu compte qu'on ne
voyait pas les saturations on a acheter
des appareils pour mesurer la saturation
à tous les gens qui se présentaient
d'accord et donc maintenant à partir de
95 ont fait les radios en fait c'est ça
ça a changé le l'anticoagulation
systématique ça a changé
voilà ce sont des choses qui ont changé
un an tout ça a changé au fur et mesure
version merci sylvie bernier
merci monsieur le président le
professeur j'aurai deux questions la
première concerne la démocratie
depuis le début de ces auditions on a
beaucoup parlé de démocratie sanitaire
en quelque sorte qu auraient été oubliés
on a oublié de d'entendre les familles
non je trouve surtout oublier d'entendre
les patients je vais vous faire un petit
témoignage personnel qui est qui rejoint
celui de milliers de personnes j'ai été
malade vers le 15 mars à un moment où il
n'était pas possible d'être testé
puisque les tests s'étaient réservés aux
soignants et on nous ait disais donc de
rester chez nous avec des boîte de
doliprane et à ce moment là les malades
de voeux n'étaient en fait que des
chiffres
on recevait tous les jours le nombre de
morts le nombre de malades et on n'était
guère plus que ça et je veux dire qu'au
moment où vous avez lancé votre votre
essai vous a été le premier à nous
donner l'espoir
je vous en sais gré je tiens à le dire
ici jusqu'à vos travaux le seul espoir
qu'on avait c'était une boîte de
doliprane voilà alors en matière de
démocratie sanitaire ça c'est une chose
mais pour le coup aujourd'hui on a le
sentiment qu'il n'ya pas de démocratie
dans le monde de la recherche
alors pourquoi est ce que c'est la force
de la pandémie qui explique ça est ce
que c'est la pression médiatique ou est
ce que c'est le fait comme vous l'avez
dit en préambule le fait qu'il n'y a pas
de patron qu'il n'est pas de leader dans
le monde des maladies infectieuses
la deuxième question portera sur le
virus vous avez déclaré récemment il
existe deux hypothèses particulièrement
plausible soit que l'épidémie
disparaisse complètement
soit que l'épidémie reprennent et
deviennent saisonnière comment ça peut
être un cas où l'autre merci je suis je
jouerai si je suis très sensible à ce
que vous dites je vais vous dire la
raison pour laquelle en pratiquant en
réalité vous ça y est souvent c'est des
anecdotes ou des moments de vie qui
déclenche de tourner les choses je pense
que je les dis à 100 mais il se trouve
qu'une fois passant un dimanche pour
voir comment les choses se passaient au
moment où elles grandissent et j'avais
une de nos assistantes qui est une fille
merveilleuse qui avait passé le week end
à qui est épuisée et elle était en train
de se disputer avec un papa a créé un
gosse de trois mois dans les bras qui
avait un masque sur le sol gosse et elle
voulait pas le tester parce que ça
faisait pas partie des critères qu'on
s'était donné donc ce type dit écoutez
moi je suis passé par un aéroport
amsterdam j'ai peur que mon gosse au
malade et je suis dit ça suffit
à découvrir aussi à partir à
tranquilliser je vois les terrifier ça
ne changeait pas les choses on peut pas
c'est tellement de vies ils étaient
négatifs
on a appris après qu'à cet âge là
c'était la plupart du temps négatif mais
on peut pas laisser les gens sans leur
proposer ou leur donner mon avis et je
pense que d'être sur le terrain
voyez c'est la raison pour laquelle je
crois tellement honorée d'être sur le
terrain ça nous a fait changer notre
manière de percevoir les choses parce
que on s'est rendu compte qu'il fallait
faire quelque chose non seulement
effectivement détecté d'abord pour les
rassurer pour leur dire s'il était ou
n'était pas positif
d'autre part pour les prendre en charge
donc sur le sur la question de
l'évolution
je ne sais pas je pondère toujours ce
que je dis en disant je crois pas au
modèle je crois pas la prédiction
tout ce par quoi moi j'arrive à
raisonner c'est par analogie d'accord
donc je dis écouter ce qui a plus proche
passe comme ça peut-être que ça va se
passer comme ça c'est la seule chose que
je peux dire
donc vous savez qu'il ya s'il y avait
six coronavirus avant en a quatre qui
sont saisonniers ils ont bien dû
commencer par être autre chose que
saisonniers comme la grippe je voulais à
la première grille au moins du xxème
siècle n'a pas du tout été saisonnière
durée de l'année elle a commencé l'été
c'est la grippe espagnole soul et puis
c'est devenu quelque chose qui est
rythmée et qui est plutôt un parent
quand il ya un nouveau variant qui est
plutôt effectivement saisonniers pour
des raisons qu'on comprend absolument
pas c'est pas le froid puisqu'il y en a
dans le sud en afrique
pendant des années les gens pensaient
qu'ils avaient pas de grip en afrique
parce qu'il pensait que tous ces flux en
faisant ça veut dire de m foods a dit
fred aux influences du froid donc ça a
été décrit vous voulez à la renaissance
comme étant une maladie qui étaient sous
influence du froid bien sûr c'était nous
qui le décrivions en europe
et comme chez nous ces saisonniers au
moment où le froid arrive on pensait que
c'est une maladie liée au froid mais il
y en a autant dans les pays chauds même
plus et la zone un portable il y en a
toute l'année et un peu plus pour
l'afrique que je connais un peu
l'afrique de l'ouest dans la plus
pendant la saison des pluies au
contraire donc on connaît on comprend
pas bien ses rythmes saisonniers mais
chez nous c'est vrai qu'il ya une
saisonnalité
tous les virus respiratoires non pas la
même saisonnalité je vous parlais de par
l'influencé 3 c'est le printemps et
l'automne
c'est pas l'hiver alors donc si par
analogie fort c'est à dire écoutez
comment à quoi ça va ressembler
analogiquement le sar ce premier hop ça
il ya une pique et s'est arrêtée en
juillet donc il ya plus de cas du tout
et on a plus depuis
d'accord les autres coronavirus qui
s'est passé c'est que il ya un moment
probablement n'a pas su quand parce
qu'on les a découvert un peu par hasard
les autres coronavirus endémique et bien
il ya probablement une diffusion qui
s'est fait un peu partout dans le monde
parce que lui est partout partout
retrouve en afrique on trouve partout en
chine et donc il le il s'est installé
maintenant durablement avec nous et il a
une d'épidémie mais au jeu
saisonnière avec quelques cas
sporadiques pendant le reste de l'année
et donc c'est les deux modèles que je
connais des eaux coronavirus demandé
écoutez aulas dans les modèles que je
connais c'est cela donc les chances que
ça ressemble au modèle qu'on connaît
déjà mais peut-être que ce sera quelque
chose de totalement différent parce que
c'est une autre maladie est une nouvelle
maladie et là en plus il est en train de
se passer des choses que moi j'avais pas
vu décrite en tout cas avec les
coronavirus et la vitesse de mutation
qu'il est actuellement
et donc je ne sais pas ce qu'il va
devenir vous n'avez pas répondu à ma
première question sur la démocratie dans
le monde la recherche qui à mon sens
écoutez je je je redoute que la
recherche auprès du tout démocratique
c'est ce que je pense que là la
recherche des clubs le sport de haut
niveau c'est pas démocratique l'idée que
c'est démocratique si vous voulez alors
dans les phases stationnaire c'est un
des grands grands épistémologique
historien des sciences dit vous savez il
ya trois phases dans un domaine de la
recherche dans un domaine particulier
il ya une première phase qui est une
phase pionnière est dans la phase
pionnière sont des gens qui sont
audacieux qui brise les lignes qui sont
poids zone et toute leur vie d'accord
c'est les pionniers et puis ensuite il
ya une phase de plateau si vous voulez
dans lequel qui est dite normale dans
lequel les choses avancent petit à petit
on rajoute un petit peu un petit peu un
petit peu c'est une phase dans lequel
qui devient collective c'est ce qu'on
appellerait la recherche démocratique
dans lequel veille les études
multicentriques avec sept pays européens
chacun rajoute un petit bout ça c'est la
face du plateau au pays malheureusement
après il ya la face du déclin c'est à
dire que le chant s'épuiser puis un
autre champ qui les kinés c'est comme ça
et c'est tout les épistémologie ce temps
observé ça s'appelait il ya des phases
et quand vous êtes à une nouvelle phase
en particulier l'arrêt phase de
découverte
le conflit sont terrifiants parce que et
c'est toute l'histoire comme ça si vous
lisez enfin moi je vous recommande de
lire mais changer d'avis un livre
merveilleux de la tour qui s'appelle
guerre et paix des microbes
la fille de pasteur c'est génial voilà
mais c'est vrai l'oeuvre scientifique
c'est pas un roman il y tous les jours
au de l'époque tous tous tout ce qui
rapporte ça pour voir comment pasteur a
réussi avec des en ayant des forces qui
était à la fois des forces politiques
des alliés qui étaient les hygiénistes
comment s'est passée l'idée du germe
ça a été un combat terrible vous savez
que la marque qui était vraiment notre
inventeur à nous de l'évolution a été
condamné à ne plus parler par un type
qui était un immense scientifique qui
était cuvier qui était à l'époque tout
puissant science et qu'il a réellement
rendu muet alors que c'était plus grands
scientifiques de l'évolution du monde
c'est c'est la vie c'est un sport de
combat
je m'excuse mon prochain livre s'appelle
la science est un sport de combat
merci vous avez par les professeurs
avant de donner la parole s'il le veut
bien dernier omis de de vitesse de
mutation
ce matin on nous a dit qu'il semblait
que le virus ne mute et pas je ne sais
pas qui a quoi moi je sais ce que j'ai
moi donc je pense qu'on fait plus de
séquences que n'importe qui donc ont
fait énormément de séquencer dans des
conditions d'ailleurs j'ai obligé de
faire venir les gens le week-end pour
pouvoir continuer à faire les séquences
donc on a fait à peu près 500 séquence
de virus depuis juillet parce qu on
était étonnés de voir la forme que
prenaient les cas cliniques et
l'épidémie depuis juillet elle
paraissait différentes donc on avait et
dès le départ on a trouvé un mutant
qu'on a appelée marseille qui est assez
online vous pouvez les regarder qui est
assez qui présentait plus de mutations
que ce qu'on avait l'habitude de voir
une 23 habitations par rapport aux la
souche de human donc on pensait qu
réellement celui et celui là on a
retracé sa source
c'est à dire on il est venu du maghreb
sur les bateaux et tous les premiers cas
ont été vraiment lié à ça et ensuite une
diffusion qui s'est passé dans
l'environnement on a eu 100 cas de ce
virus là actuellement ce virus-là à peu
près disparu depuis août et on pensait
que c'est lui qui avait plus le truc et
on a maintenant 7 mi temps
celui qui est le plus
celui qui est le plus actif actuellement
c'est sûr on a appelé quatre una 60
cartes du 4 et globalement si vous
voulez si vous regardez le nom mais vous
voyez bien quand on peut pas parler de
la même chose
moi je vous assure c'est des données je
viens de les écrire ces données calais a
gardé son online parce que mon mais
effectivement c'est une de zorro de
cette fumée tout online maintenant en
particulier la destituer sur un public
pour que tout le monde puisse en
profiter
si on regarde nous tous les virus que
nous avons eu jusqu'en mai et qu'on
regarde l'heure si vous regardez sur
notre site vous le verrez on a beaucoup
réfléchi pour leur présenter de manière
qui est visible sur un cercle
le degré de variation par rapport à la
souche initial si vous regardez la
différence entre les différentes souches
que nous avions par rapport à la souche
initial elle donnait un cercle diamètre
x
si vous regardez maintenant ce que nous
avons depuis juillet ce diamètre a été
multiplié par dix c'est à dire la
variabilité des virus que nous avons
maintenant les virus que nous allons
maintenant son antre présente entre eux
dix fois plus de variations que les
virus que nous avions jusqu'en mai
d'accord et c'est des variations qui
sont très intéressantes parce que sont
des variations convoi dans la
dégradation des génomes en général c'est
à dire c'est d'aider des variations
c'est qu'à quatre bases génétiques
qui sont intéressés pour l'adn et pour
les virus à arn la place d'un thé vous
avez eue et donc la dégradation de ces
verrues est une normalement et réparer
parce que la plupart du temps elle est
délétère et donc là ce convoi
majoritairement c'est des mutations de
tv rue qui traduisent soit l'effet d'une
enzyme qui est bien connu chez les
humains qui s'appelle à pour beck qui a
l'habitude de couper les russes donc
peut-être qu'au fur et à mesure que ce
virus s'est répandu et est arrivée des
formes qui qui qui qui permettent la
transformation de ces verrues soit il
est donc soit il se passe quelque chose
dans ce virus qui permet ça mais ce que
je peux vous dire leur sens là aussi
étudié peut-être que delfraissy n'a pas
vu encore mais moi je les ai vus parce
qu'on a envoyé le papier on a comparé
100 cas à partir de juillet et ce en
paca avant pour regarder quel était le
degré de leurs troubles de coagulation
et donc ils ont beaucoup moins de
troubles de coagulation ils sont moins
sévères et la mortalité plus faible
donc il se passe quelque chose avec ce
lyrisme qui en fait quelque chose de
différent voilà et donc moi je regrette
voyez que on vous dit ça passe moi j'ai
téléphoné au conseiller du ministre pour
lui dire et pour lui donner et donner
donc la question que vous me posiez
toutes les semaines je téléphone donc en
tant que dernier qui est le conseiller
du ministre pour lui dire écoute je vais
parler de ça voilà ce que nous avons si
vous le voulez les données vous les avez
jeu je reste à l'intérieur d'une
démocratie où je partage mes résultats
mais je les partage ensuite avec la
plaque dentaire 100 cas permettez moi
d'insister parce que la ferme me semble
d'importance sans qu'à comparer prêt
avant et après le mois de mai c'est
suffisant pour je ne sais pas ce que
vous appelez suffisant loban moi non
plus moi non plus mais global board mais
ce suffisant pour affirmer oui à
mutation ah non mais il avoue ses
constatations c'est rien n'avance pas
l'habitation c'est un truc qu'on
constate dans le virus donc dont on a
fait 550 de génomes viraux d'accord donc
la place de juillet août
c'est visible on voit à la place d'avoir
cette base cette balle quoi
on s'est rendu compte nouer d'autres que
l'on pouvait séquence est directement
les virus avec les nouvelles on peut
peut séquencer les virus maintenant
directement en dehors de sans avoir
besoin de cultiver d'accord avec lui tu
es beaucoup mais pratiquement chez tous
ceux qui ont moins de 20 ct on peut
avoir le virus entier dans huit heures
qui suivent le génome entier
huit heures qui suivent dont il voulait
de pratiquer des génomes quand on a tous
encore une fois c'est à dire on a le
prélèvement on voit que les c'était son
bas on peut les envoyer
on peut les envoyer en séquences et puis
on a nous un mécanisme d' analyse des
séquences qui nous permet de voir ça
voilà bien le papier sur notre site
seulement nous perdrons tout cela bien
sûr avec beaucoup d'intérêt bernard
jomier merci monsieur le président je
voudrais monsieur présent revenir sur
votre propos liminaires et parce que le
professeur à outils a répondu et je
voudrais le lui expliquer quel était
l'intérêt de notre démarche qui a été de
vouloir vous auditionnés en présence et
on débat avec d'autres spécialistes
d'autres personnalités ayant une
compétence éminentes comme la vôtre
c'est une méthode que nous utilisons
couramment dans cette commission enquête
pourquoi parce que et la discussion qui
vient d'avoir lieu le démontre
parfaitement vous pouvez avec un savoir
technique qui est incomparable aux
nôtres en la matière nous faire un
exposé pendant 10 minutes de virologie
pour nous expliquer que le virus semble
muté mais un autre virologue et milan le
professeur lina nous a expliqué et nous
a dit plusieurs fois que non le virus
n'avait pas muté et ça ça ne fait pas
beaucoup avancer notre compréhension
nous nous nous avons besoin nous ne
sommes pas dans des conflits
ce n'est pas notre méthode ici de mettre
en scène des matchs de catch et de
générer du conflit c'est notre méthode
de faire ressortir les points qui font
clivages et si pour vous ça peut être
pénible parce que
vous avez des conflits avec d'autres
collègues d'autres confrères qui sont
parfois effectivement virulent nous ce
n'est pas ce que nous ce n'est pas notre
jaillir ce n'est pas notre problème j'en
suis tout à fait désolé pour les uns et
les autres mais nous nous devons rendre
compte aux français aux personnes qui
résident sur notre territoire de ce qui
s'est passé et sur ces sujets
fondamentaux qui sont les vôtres la
recherche les tests le dépistage
vous faites partie des personnes qui
avaient une expertise et qui ont été en
désaccord avec d'autres et pouvoir vous
entendre vous répondre entre vous et
pour nous essentiel dans la construction
de notre représentation et notre
compréhension de ce qui se passe ce qui
s'est passé de ce qui se passe voilà
donc je vais pas poursuivre là dessus
mais comprenez juste que nous ne
souhaitions pas vous faire vivre un
moment pénible pour vous à titre
personnel je comprends que ce n'est pas
agréable d'être poursuivi devant des
instances disciplinaires d'avoir des
procédures en justice mais nous nous
avons la nécessité de mener notre
travail dans les meilleures conditions
et très tranquillement professeurs avec
le respect que je vous dois vous ne nous
aidez pas là dans notre tâche votre
exposé est certes très intéressant mais
il ne nous ils ne mettent pas à
progresser de façon suffisante alors je
veux en venir à quelques à quelques
quelques questions ah non vous allez
répondre inter milan fait pas et vous
allez région venir à quelques
questionnements parce que vous avez là
la tension je dirais de nous envoyer en
préliminaire à cette audition un
document extrêmement complet de réponse
à notre question ce matin nous
débattions et ne l'avions fait au
rapporteur par le rapporteur
mais vous ne vous inquiétez pas je
circulais vous avez tout comprendre ce
matin nous avons eu une discussion et
les jours lors d'auditions présente sur
la question des tests et de la lenteur
refait pas l'histoire du déploiement des
thèses dans notre pays et au printemps
quand nous étions en pleine vague
épidémique
nous voyons tous devant votre institut
des fils de personnes qui venaient pour
faire des têtes et vous pratiquiez
beaucoup de tests et dont le
document vous nous avez envoyé vous
dites j'ai fait deux cent mille nous
avons faits liés à je suis deux cent
mille tests sur cent mille personnes
alors est ce que vous pourriez nous
préciser ce calendrier est comme
manifestement vous avez commencé à faire
des tests en nombre très rapidement
comment avez vous fait comment vous êtes
vous procurer le matériel nécessaire les
réactifs et c'est alors que ailleurs en
france
bah on n'arrivait pas à faire de tel
donc manifestement vous avez réussi là
où là où on échoué plus tôt donc
j'aimerais que vous me préciser comment
vous avez procédé
la deuxième question c'est vous nous
avez dit quelque chose de très fort mais
nous vous nous avez dit il ya une
destruction physique de l'organisation
des maladies infectieuses
si j'ai bien compris à paris enfin en
ile-de-france mais j'aimerais que vous
précisiez qu'est ce que c'est que cette
destruction parce que il me semble mais
peut-être le démon tirez-vous alors j'ai
vu aussi qu'il ya eu des polémiques là
dessus mais il me semble que globalement
les patients qui ont été hospitalisés en
maladies infectieuses en ile de france
n'ont pas eu de perte de chance par
rapport à ceux qui ont été hospitalisés
en maladies infectieuses dans d'autres
régions donc qu'est-ce que cette
destruction physique dont vous avez
parlé j'ai compris que le fait d'avoir
scindé géographiquement mais j'imagine
des services des capacités mais
j'imagine que ça allait au delà puisque
la critique est très dur et puis enfin
dernier point que je ne souhaitais pas
soulevé parce que c'est pas l'obliger
exactement ici mais vous êtes vous êtes
revenu sur diderot xi chloroquine et
l'azithromycine et vous avez dans votre
exposé préliminaire expliqué un principe
qui me paraîtrait et récent celui du
benchmark vous vous regardez ce qu'il
fallait et rangez vous avez cité la
chine est important savoir qu'elle a qui
là qu'elle a accumulées aujourd'hui il
semblerait que la plupart des pays de
des états unis au japon la corée du sud
à l'allemagne en passant par la chine ne
recommande pas ce traitement là donc il
semblerait que la science a parlé et
c'est la liste des pays qui ont qu'ils
ne recommandent pas ou qui même
déconseillent l'utilisation
l'hydro xi chloroquine est extrêmement
longue j'en ai j'ai cité juste quelques
pays et ça ce n'est pas un jugement sûr
c'est tout à fait sain de d'entrée quand
nouveaux problèmes arrivent dans la
recherche de médicaments de traitement
possible et deham tenter de trouver que
ça pourrait être efficace mais
aujourd'hui comprenez que nous qui
sommes on va dire des spectateurs
engagés de cette question et la prise en
charge
on constate que dans le monde entier ce
traitement n'est plus utilisé donc est
ce que ça signifie que le monde entier
est aujourd'hui dans l'erreur merci vous
inquiétez pas vous allez pouvoir
répondre merci bernard de ces questions
donc je vous donne la parole professeurs
pour la réponse pourrait donc je pense
je ne suis pas d'accord du tout et vous
bien sûr sur aucun des points le premier
point le premier point c'est que la
question est peinte et ce n'est pas un
débat entre non mais si vous avez des
affirmations auxquelles je suis en total
désaccord et à 4,6 milliards de gens qui
vivent dans d'autres pays dans lequel on
vit dedans livre cycloclean donc vous
pouvez pas liquidé ça comme ça je passe
mon temps à faire des méta-analyses rien
que cette semaine il est sorti ce qui
est de sortie en arabie saoudite et en
iran
il en sort à peu près dans tous les pays
du monde donc on ne peut pas dire ça
vous pouvez pas me dire à moi vous savez
mieux que moi ce que c'est que les méta
analyse sur l'hydroxyde rocklyn vous
avez une opinion et vous voyez bien
qu'il n'est pas possible de ce répit on
sait le temps qu'il fait les opinions
vous savez encore une fois si vous aviez
demandé au départ à quoi sert la 14ème
mois je le disais à partir de février à
14h c'est un fantasme analogique avec la
quarantaine ça n'a pas de sens sur le
plan clinique c'est pas vrai d'accord il
ya d'ailleurs une une étude de méta
analyse qui fait partie du rapport que
je vous ai envoyés et que bien entendu
il peut être distribué à tout le monde
la deuxième chose c'est que le temps
encore une fois fait le tri au début les
gens disaient ça ne sert à rien de faire
des tests pourquoi ils n'ont pas fait
des tests par c'est parce que les
centres nationaux de référence lors on
dit écoutez c'est compliqué difficile de
faire les tests et une fois que cet
embranchement était parti est
extrêmement difficile de revenir sur
sept en branche
extrêmement difficile et donc c'est pas
vrai qu'ils avaient pas les réactifs je
les dis je le redis puis je vous le
redis encore une fois si vous voulez les
laboratoires vétérinaires ont écrit à
peu près à tout le monde y compris au
conseil scientifique pour leur dire
qu'ils avaient à faire quoi 300 mille
tests et les autres l'auront pas répondu
et nous on a répondu et on s'en est
servi
d'accord donc vous ne pouvez pas penser
que dans une crise comme ça où il ya des
opinions différentes
vous avez les par la magie du sénat
faire que les gens votent d'accord la
fin c'est le temps qui trient le temps
tri et à la fin on voit ce qui s'est
passé d'accord c'est à la fin qu'on voit
ce qui s'est passé quand encore une fois
à la ligue roc cyclo pin et donc pour
les tests on a fait ce qu'on fait quand
on est en situation de crise c'est à
dire tous les jours on s'est débrouillé
nous mêmes on a fabriqué de quoi faire
430 mille tests nous même chez nous
l'eau phillies est d'accord on s'est
organisé pour faire face ces
l'intendance qui a suivi la décision
c'est pas la tendance qui a commandé
décision c'est comme ça qu'on a vu les
choses et c'est comme ça que je
continuerai à les voir
quant à votre opinion sur qui et kindle
fire aussi chloroquine je vous assure je
viens d'avoir un papier accepté sur
lequel on a mis l'ensemble des pays qui
recommandait roxy chloroquine la
mortalité dans l'ensemble des pays qui a
gardé avec lockheed et ça n'est pas ce
que vous dites donc je ne suis pas
d'accord
donc vous évitez vous émettez une
opinion scientifique et donc vous voyez
je ne suis pas de corps et donc que
chacun fasse son métier et les vaches
regardent et vous entendrez deux éco et
le temps triera à la fin on verra bien
si vous nous bien sûr tu as
c'est donc c'est je ne sais pas encore
dans le document je crois c'est dans le
jeu qui membres c'est dans le document
que nous communiquons bien sûr
l'ensemble de nos conseillers parce que
la lecture est intéressant de nos
commissaires par monsieur le président
je ne suis pas dans un débat d'opinion
je suis rapporteur d'une je suis
rapporteur d'une commission denquête et
professeurs je vais vous citer une liste
incomplète d'ailleurs des pays qui
actuellement dont les autorités de santé
déconseille usage de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine
si ce que disent ces autorités est
inexact je veux bien l'entendre je viens
d'entendre votre opinion qui ne la
partage pas mais vous ne pouvez pas dire
que c'est une opinion de ma part aux usa
la haine ni h et ligne fictions diseases
society of america déconseillent
l'utilisation l'aude roxy chloroquine en
grande bretagne c'est déconseillé dans
le monde l'organisation mondiale de la
santé de demande de ne pas l'utiliser
quelle que soit la gravité l'italie
déconseille la belgique déconseille
l'allemagne déconseille le brésil le
portugal la chine le chinese center for
disease control and prevention estime
que l'utilisation doit être déconseillé
quelle que soit la gravité le japon
l'australie l'espagne le canada
l'european medicines agency pour
l'europe la suisse et la corée du sud
je n'aimais pas une opinion si ces
recommandations sont erronées je peux
l'entendre et jeu j'attends qu'on nous
l'expliquent mais je ne vais pas mené de
débats scientifiques avec vous ce n'est
pas le sujet je réfute simplement
professeur le fait que vous transformiez
ma question en un débat d'opinion entre
vous et moi je respecte votre opinion et
je vous aimez les recommandations des
pays concernés encore une fois je vous
recommande de vous verrez encore une
fois on a un papier dans lequel on
explique ça est extrêmement précisément
sondés général vous savez pour pour
faire des généralités trouvé qu'on est
d'accord c'est extrêmement simple moi je
peux vous dire aux états unis et
agissent un pays fédéral il ya un tiers
des états dans lequel hydroxy floraux
qui n'est recommandée il ya un tiers des
états dans lequel certains trop ce qu'il
faut faire et un tiers des états qui
suivent les recommandations de faux si
c'est un pays fédéral
donc il n'ya pas d'homogénéité aux états
unis et compare même aux états unis à
des conflits les conflits autour de
l'hydroxyde de routine sont mondiaux et
avec qui compare même aux états unis
état par état
quelle est la mortalité et au co vide
par rapport à la prescription ou non
d'une roxy du rocky
pardon la liste oui oui vous les
regarderai la liste nous on a fait une
liste on a marqué chaque source
à chaque de chaque source d'où elle
vient comment elle fait comme on fait de
la séance donc vous vous le lirez vous
avez si vous souhaitez que je vous
enlevez le vol près print je vous
enverrai n'y a pas de problème mais moi
je sais ce que je fais je trouve que
c'est un sujet sur lequel vous imaginez
bien qu'on travaille
nous on a estimé qu'il y avait 4 6 4 1 6
milliard de gens qui vivaient dans les
pays auxquels ont recommandé ou entre
ont dit vous pouvez tirer la lidho xique
la routine se voulait donc il encore une
fois donc ça veut dire que ces débats
qui sont des débats scientifiques très
bien nous on l'a écrit il ya une liste
une liste des sources comme on a
l'habitude de faire et puis et puis
voilà vous regarderez si vous arrivez à
les analyser
où vous les ferez analysés par quelqu'un
qui vous aidera à les analyser mais on
ne peut pas de manière péremptoire dire
écoutez tous ces pays là ne le font pas
et ne l'ont pas fait se passe parce que
c'est pas mal ça n'est pas les donner
merci il y avait la question sur les
tests donc vous dites vous êtes s'est
constitué vous même vous avez fait vous
même vos tests pour arriver à ce nombre
et puis vous les avez eu au niveau des
laboratoires vétérinaires et ça n'a pas
été ça n'a pas été très rapidement pris
en compte sur le plan national quoi un
retard par rapport à écouter mozart ou
non j'ai eu l'occasion de dire au
président qui m'a confirmé quand j'ai
revu que la pcr est une chose
extrêmement simple qui posait pas
beaucoup de problèmes et que tout le
monde était capable de faire comme on
voit maintenant et à l'époque il a été
surpris et quand il est revenu il m'a
dit écoutez c'est vrai vous avez été
premier à me dire ça on me disait que
c'était un truc très compliquée qui
pourrait être fait dans les centres de
référence donc il est parti un
régulièrement
donc si vous voulez là encore je ne
crois pas que quand on soit dans une
situation comme ça parce que je me suis
déjà trouvé
si vous voulez on puisse avoir un débat
entre les gens qui s'est quand même la
chose la plus simple du monde parce que
nous on en faisait déjà derrière 150000
de pc que l'adn c'est l'adn
si vous voulez et puis les gens qui
disent non c'est très compliqué et c'est
très complexe et le temps qu'ils trient
et c'est pas ici et maintenant qu'on va
trier tous les éléments qui sont liées à
cette donnée pour l'autre question que
vous posez non il faut regarder les
morts vous les regarderai les morts moi
je les connais les morts je sais qui est
mort dans quelle ville dans quelles
régions et communes mort et combien une
jeune qui sont je le sais bien
donc je connais les résultats là aussi
il faut aller regarder les résultats et
regarder les otages et publié d'ailleurs
les résultats et c'est ceux de santé
publique france c'est pas les miens il
faut garder bien il ya une morale il ya
une surmortalité ici et dans l'est qui
est tout à fait spécifique quelque chose
de particulier avec une vraie
surmortalité et y compris dans des
tranches d'âge où on n'a pas l'habitude
de voir une surmortalité donc si vous
voulez d'ailleurs si en pratique de ne
pas traiter pas des moustiques et les
gens c'était la même chose que quand on
les traite et diagnostic on souhaite
plutôt merci les questions des
rapporteurs étant terminée j'invite
maintenant le commissaire a posé les
questions j'ai déjà 3 3 6 6 3 9 11
inscriptions donc je vais les prendre
quelques-uns par quelques-uns et vous
répondrais de façon collective en notant
après de façon groupée
merci davance martin livriez merci
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
professeur rappelle je vous rappelle
simplement que nous excuse moi tu avoir
prouvé martin que nous devons finir nos
travaux pour 17 17 heures voilà il est
16 heures 13 très bien que quelques
questions j'espère rapide
la première que je reprends le début de
cette pandémie on est dans une pandémie
arrive assez rapidement une controverse
scientifique qui qui prend toute la
place au niveau communication et presse
et de cette controverse on arrive même à
un combat scientifique
je ne suis ni médecin ni spécialiste et
je suis avalé par ce combat par cette
inquiétude qui met entre nous tous parce
qu'on ne comprend pas tout et ça fait
quatre points que ce combat dur perdure
et continue et je me dis qu'aujourd'hui
il ya peut-être une possibilité de s'en
sortir mais là c'est vous qui pouvez
vraiment mai
vous avez déjà donné un élément de
réponse tollé en disant idéologiquement
je ne peux pas et pourtant je me pose la
question
ce combat qui ne méritent pas je trouve
d'être pourrait s'arrêter si vous
décidiez vous parce que vous en avez la
capacité les moyens et aujourd'hui
malheureusement visiblement le les
passions puisque ya de plus en plus de
patients et de malades dans votre
département de faire justement ces
essais en double aveugle parce que
finalement on se dit je comprends votre
principe de dire pas de placebo pour les
parce que parce qu'il ya des gens qui
n'ont pas être soigné mais aujourd'hui
si vous avez raison si vous aviez raison
depuis le début combien de patients
n'ont pas été soignées parce que
finalement on a préféré l'idéologie à
une tentative dont je vous pose vraiment
cette question parce qu'elle me paraît
tellement importante aujourd'hui de se
dire si vous avez raison professeurs
c'est tellement important aujourd'hui si
vous avez raison et ce que l'idéologie
est supérieur à le fait d'avoir raison
donc voilà ma première question
la deuxième concerne indirectement cela
aussi c'est la communication est ce
qu'aujourd'hui la communication n'a pas
pris le pas sur le vrai travail
scientifique et sur ce besoin de
controverses qui est indispensable je
pense dans le monde scientifique mais
comme partout ailleurs et qu'aujourd'hui
on est plus dans la controverse non le
combat et comment on sort de ce débat
pour avancer pour permettre au monde
entier s'en sortir parce que c'est un
sujet mondial c'est pas un sujet franco
français et bah écoutez ça sera tout
pour le moment parce que j'avais autre
question mais je les ai perdus merci
président bonjour professeur je suis
sénateur des français établis hors de
france
vous bénéficiez d'une grande renommée
une reconnaissance parmi les trois
millions et demi de français qui vivent
à l'étranger
je voulais vous poser une question cette
pandémie a débuté en asie à toucher à
peu près simultanément l'europe et de
l'amérique du nord puis
l'amérique latine au mois d'avril du
quai d'orsay en passant par de nombreux
experts des projections catastrophique
était annoncé sur l'afrique
certains pays on avait même le nombre de
respirateurs je pense entre autres à
l'ethiopie par habib par centaines ou
par million d'habitants on avait le mali
on avait l'egypte et un certain nombre
de pays qui finalement n'ont pas connu
ces vagues aussi importante que dans
d'autres territoires
vous-même français d'étrangers vous vous
connaissez très bien l'afrique et le
sénégal en particulier et j'aimerais
savoir pourquoi et comment vous
expliquez que cette catastrophe annoncée
n'a pas eu lieu et quel est votre
diagnostic et enfin une dernière
question très rapide avec plus de dix
mille cas en 24 heures ces derniers
temps on peut comprendre l'anxiété de la
société face à cette pandémie
si vous aviez trois recommandations à
faire quelle serait-elle
trois recommandations quelle serait-elle
et comment voyez vous l'évolution de
cette pandémie dans les deux mois qui
viennent puisque c'est là qu'on nous
annonce aussi selon les sources des avis
très divergents
merci merci roger karoutchi plus
professeur moi je partage la dernière
question d'ailleurs de mon ami régnard
c'est vrai qu'on aimerait tous avoir un
peu votre opinion sur ce qui va se
passer ou ce qui pourrait se passer dans
les semaines qui viennent moi je
voudrais poser deux questions assez
clair 1
qu'est ce que vous pensez du fait que
les médecins libéraux que les médecins
tout court pour beaucoup ont été bien
souvent contraints de ne pas appliquer
votre traitement et de ne pas pouvoir le
prescrire à un moment où dans le même
temps les mêmes autorités scientifiques
affirmait qu'il n'y avait pas de
traitement qu'il n'y avait pas de
médicaments et que dans ses conséquences
dans ces conditions les gens comme
disait ma collègue sylvie vermeillet
soit on leur disait vous prendrez le
doliprane
soit ils pouvaient avoir votre
traitement et si ça n'était pas ça il
n'y avait en tout cas au début rien est
ce que c'est normal dans en 2020 dans un
pays comme le nôtre de dire à des gens à
qui on dit vous êtes positif
vous restez chez vous priez et prenez du
doliprane
est ce que c'est normal ma deuxième
question ma deuxième question elle et
elle est simple ce matin je disais au
professeur delfraissy
j'ai beaucoup d'estimé pour le conseil
scientifique pour chacun de ses membres
on sait pas le sujet mais la réalité
elle est quand même que l'autorité du
conseil scientifique ne semble pas
toujours être suivie par le gouvernement
ce qui veut dire que on a
institutionnalisé un débat sur mon
passionnant entre scientifiques médecins
dans les médias et ailleurs mais qui en
réalité extrêmement anxiogènes pour la
population est ce que dans ces
conditions là vous pensez que le conseil
scientifique tel que défini avec les
missions qui sont les siennes a encore
du sens aujourd'hui
olivier henno
oui merci professeur pour vos propos -
j'ai une question qui est en
prolongement et que le débat de ce matin
ce matin on nous a dit le système de
santé français n'était pas prêt alors on
a eu quelques explications un peu
complexe un peu flou parmi lesquels oui
mais un autre système de santé il est
trop curatif
alors ma question elle concerne votre
que diagnostic par rapport à notre
système de santé
pourquoi nous n'étions pas prêts moi je
pense que ça n'est pas seulement une
question de moyens puisque notre pays
consacre un certain nombre de moyens
à son système de santé je pense que
c'est plus une question d'organisation
et d'ailleurs on nous a dit aussi que
parmi les pays qui étaient mieux
préparés il y avait l'allemagne et puis
je m'interroge aussi sur le fait que
notre système
[Musique]
comme beaucoup de choses en france
d'ailleurs et souvent un peu trop
corporatistes et donc je voulais votre
diagnostic sur sur toutes ces questions
je vous remercie
sapin oui oui professeur président merci
de deux questions très rapide parce que
vous y avez répondu en partie déjà
néanmoins je voudrais quelques
précisions sur la première elle concerne
la relation à la chine
ce matin le professeur delfraissy au nom
du conseil scientifique nous disait que
les informations qu'il avait lui-même en
échange direct avec les chinois sous
l'oeil bienveillant de l' oms nous
faisait comprendre dans ses propos qu'il
n'avait qu'une confiance très très
réservé sur ce que les chinois nous
apporter aussi bien en termes
scientifiques cliniques et qu'il doutait
fort de beaucoup de leurs propos quant à
vous effectivement vous êtes appuyé au
départ quand vous avez lancé le
processus chloroquine en disant voilà
c'est peut-être la solution est
aujourd'hui moi je n'ai pas un regard
assez assez pertinent ni même assez
globale pour juger de l'efficacité ou
non mais en tout cas vous êtes appuyé
sur les expertises chinoise pour dire
voilà en chine il ya quelque chose qui
marche et bien testons le en france donc
je voudrais savoir quelle qu'elle est en
fait cette relation et cette différence
entre les apports du conseil
scientifique et puis ce que vous vous
avez décrété puis deuxièmement je
voudrais qu'on revienne sur la mutation
la mutation et les souches vous nous
dites
effectivement il ya de plus en plus de
souche en tout cas c'est ce que vous
constatez c'est ce que j'ai cru
comprendre dans votre exposé mais ce qui
fait les choux les souches
c'est les mutations du virus des
différentes souches de virus qu'on
rencontre elles proviennent de la
mutation du virus
qu'elles soient ou non plus pathogène
plus virulente mais en tout cas elles
viennent de là donc ce qu'on voudrait
savoir simplement parce que tous les
gens qui nous écoutent c'est ce qu'il
entendent à la radio ou à la télé le
virus mute il oui ou non parce que ce
matin on nous a dit non
oui merci beaucoup monsieur le président
monsieur le professeur
j'ai une poignée à questions concernant
les essais thérapeutiques vous avez des
protocoles
alors est-ce que des hameaux de
connaissances vous avez évoqué la
bibliographie que vous avez faite
concernant les chinois mais est ce que
dans ce que vous préconisiez il ya eu
des études comparatives qui sera fait en
fonction de vos préconisations
parce que bon il ya des personnes qui
ont dit que ce n'est pas forcément
pertinent
donc est-ce que vous avez connaissance
de l'équipe qui aurait utilisé
conformément à vos recommandations au
protocole la deuxième chose la liberté
de la liberté de prescrire a été mise en
cause dans notre pays alors pensez vous
qu'il ya eu des pertes de change liées à
cette liberté à cette obstruction
la dernière chose revient alors cela
concerne également les mutations
alors je voudrais savoir vous avez dit
qu'il y avait quand vous avez commandé
des binômes que vous avez fait des
séquençages il ya eu elle vous avez eue
et cette mutation
alors sur quoi portait ces mutations s
des mutations ou des permutations
d'acides aminés à quel niveau il y avait
ces mutations pour que ce sera un peu
plus clair pour tout le monde
je vous remercie mr si vous allez
répondre à cette première salve la
deuxième suivra pour les les premières
questions
si vous voulez je suis content que vous
me posez cette question mais je me
demande pourquoi vous la posez pas au
ministère la santé parce que c'était pas
compliqué de dire ce qu'il ya des gens
qui adorent faire des essais pourquoi
ils ont pas fait un essai en cycle à
hockey night raw be seen contre placebo
combat donc globalement globalement ce
que vous voulez et c'est une des
reproches majeurs que j'ai fait pour ce
rapport ce conseil scientifique c'est
que tous les essais avaient été décidés
avant que la moindre réunion du conseil
scientifique
il était question que du raid m6 viré du
lopinavir jamais l'hydroxyde nothing qui
était le seul pour lequel on avait des
données préliminaires et qu' il n'y a
jamais eu d'organisation c'est le comité
scientifique n'a pas été c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles je me suis mis
en retrait de ce conseil scientifique
ce conseil scientifique n'a jamais
piloté quoi que ce soit par cherche
locaux vides rien et donc qui sait qui a
apporté les données pour savoir que les
enfants n'étaient pas affectés c'est
nous toutes les données vous avez là ça
me fait ça m'amuse beaucoup que les gens
parlent de maintenant qui découvre que
les ct n'ont pas tous la même valeur
ça fait deux mois et demi qu'on l'a
écrit non quand même donc le débat il
est cette semaine
alors donc ça c'est des choses que le
pilotage de l'état aurait dû faire
aurait dû dire écoutez dites nous
quelles sont les limites du s'étaient
dites nous quelle est l'incidence des
différentes couches de populations dites
nous quelle est l'incidence chez les
patients symptomatiques et
asymptomatiques
ça c'est du pilotage d'accord et ce
pilotage
c'est le conseil scientifique et de le
faire et je peux vous le dire j'ai écrit
très tôt en disant écoutez ce conseil
scientifique ne peut pas piloter une
recherche de crise et j'ai fait les
propositions dont je me suis au thé
parce que je je je pensais que je
continue à penser que le plus utile à
faire ça sur place parce quelle décision
prendre tous les jours et que le temps à
tort ou à raison capable de le faire
mais j'ai proposé des gens qui faisait
des centaines de milliers de pc r j'ai
proposé aux portes de toulouse et celui
de créteil
j'ai proposé des gens qui connaissaient
parfaitement la pharmacopée la
pharmacologie j'aurais jamais validé
hallyday claude sicard qui est un poison
mortel
donc il y avait des gens qui étaient
capables de mener une véritable
politique scientifique ce conseil
scientifique n'était pas fait de gens
qui étaient capables de mener une
politique scientifique donc je le dis je
exprimé au président de la république et
au premier ministre peut pas faire plus
donc je regrette
effectivement il fallait faire une
politique très bien ont ils ont écouté
puisque c'est comme ça
vérifier ce que dira raul qu'il a
quelques éléments préliminaires commence
à les traiter comme ça fait le tour pour
répondre à votre question sur
l'efficacité
oui avant que ce soit interdit dans les
ehpad nous avons commencé à faire une
étude qui est là aussi
online que vous pouvez regarder dans
l'est
ehpad sur lequel nous avons une baisse
de 50 % de la mortalité dans les étapes
dans lequel on a pu traiter les gens par
rapport aux endroits on n'a pas pu les
traiter c'est à vous allez passer de 27
à 14 %
c'est nos données aussi il faut le
garder voilà puis il faut faire pareil
plutôt que diraient les ehpad en faire
donc je je pense qu'il ya encore le
temps et encore les malades
je pense que les gens qui se posent la
question moi je me pose pas la question
c'est pas moi qu'il faut la poser la
question et non seulement je me la pose
pas mais là non plus il faut pas vivre
dans des mythes truc il ya un énorme
papier qui est sorti aux états unis
american journal of medecine qui
expliquent où est la place de
l'hydroxyde de routine d'après eux en
particulier au départ du fait de son
rôle contre les facteurs qui entraînent
la coagulation à la coagulation est en
partie due à la sécrétion d'auto
anticorps et d'anticorps anti
phospholipides qui sont les mêmes
anticorps qu'on trouve dans le lupus et
c'est la raison pourquoi on donne et
roxy de la routine dans le plus donc
tout ça sont des éléments là aussi c'est
intéressant de parler de science
donc ça c'est des éléments dont on à la
réalité maintenant vous parler de
communication en la communication
personnellement je pense et j'ai
toujours pensé que la manière dont vous
voyez les choses on partait dans le mur
c'est ce que je pense donc moi je n'ai
fait que je n'ai jamais porté d'opinion
à part quand vous me le demandez dans
une situation officielle sur la
politique du gouvernement je n'ai porté
je n'ai fait que donner des chiffres et
les données que nous avions et que nous
étions les seuls à voir dans ce pays et
parfois les seuls à vendre
d'accord j'ai fait que ça donc et vous
les avez je suis désolé je pensais qu'on
le transmettra à tout le monde vous
savez jeu sans limites
quatre pages de résultats de ce que nous
faisons et qui est officiel que l'on
peut pas tricher avec sa enfin ses
défauts lignac lé regard des accords
donc encore une fois équipe usée
c'est vrai que cette même communication
que j'ai fait peut-être que vous trouvez
qu'elle est nuisible mais il ya une
quantité de pays qu'ils ont utilisé
cette communication pour prendre des
mesures et pour prendre des mesures qui
ont été fonctionnelle moi j'ai des amis
en algérie je vous assure qu'ils
testaient plus que ce contest en france
à ce moment là d'accord parce que il
avait compris qu'il fallait rester
d'accord donc il y avait une faut pas me
sortir l'angleterre il est sorti des
papiers aux états unis
et en angleterre sur les meilleurs
journaux du monde où les gens affirmé
qu'ils avaient que un traitement et
marcher ou pas marcher sans même avoir
fait un test biologique
donc il ya un phénomène de déroute qui
n'est pas que français il ya un vrai
phénomène de dents qui écoute et où est
ce qu'on va où est ce qu'on va
et pour revenir je m'excuse pour les
chinois qui étaient posées pour une
autre question pourquoi moi je pense que
ça des chinois les chinois sont
actuellement les seuls compétiteurs que
nous ayons sur la science que nous
faisons sont tous en extrême orient
c'est taiwan c'est la chine sa corée du
sud c'est eux qui ont actuellement si
vous voulez savoir les infections
respiratoires les plus grandes salles et
du monde sont toutes là ils ont pris une
approche extrêmement pragmatique
extrêmement moderne et nos concurrents
c'est à chaque fois je peux vous dire
des choses on essaie de faire
actuellement vers du séquençage direct
d'infection du cerveau une affection du
coeur est tout content parce qu'on a un
truc qu'on commence à écrire le papier
il ya un papier qui a été publiée avant
nous par des chinois dans un journal
dont vous avez jamais entendu parler
mais on est du coup on n'est pas les
premiers ça ne vous avez de beaucoup
donc si vous voulez les chinois
actuellement ont une stratégie et que
moi j'ai vu et qui m'a relancé à un
moment où j'étais un peu découragé pour
lâcher quand j'ai vu ce qu'ils ont fait
à shanghai je vous assure fait une
délégation pour voir l'hôpital qu'à côté
de shanghai pour faire les maladies
infectieuses comprenez comment voyez
comment ils soignent un jeu pour dire il
ya pas un truc vous regardez vous voulez
vous n'avez même pas je m'excuse de dire
ça mais vous n'avez même pas
l'équivalent en maladies infectieuses de
ce qui est actuellement au sénégal au
mali où pour congo ici d'accord au
sénégal si vous allez à côté de
l'aéroport du sénégal scheme ou aps
là je peux vous dire payer par gilead
d'ailleurs il ya un bâtiment
technologique dans lequel il ya un
niveau d'équipements de diagnostic et de
séquences qui est absolument inouïe
donc il ya une course technologique qui
s'est mise en avant dans lequel il ya
une partie six pays qui n'a pas suivi et
l cette course technologique elle fait
passer en extrême orient pour pour ce
qui se passe en afrique chez lui
pourquoi je sais jamais un jeu c'est
après dire et deuxièmement je ne sais
pas pourquoi ce qui se passe en afrique
espace en afrique alors
il est possible que en tout cas c'est ce
que disent beaucoup d'africains travail
est possible que le fait qu'ils prennent
de la chloroquine systématiquement et
joue un rôle dans la diffusion de la
maladie c'est possible honnêtement j'en
sais rien je ne miserais pas là dessus
c'est une constatation qu'on peut faire
si on généralise à al usage ou pas c'est
comme ça concernant l'anxiété ça moi je
veux bien répondre à ça ça m'intéresse
beaucoup y apprend vous admettrez que
l'anxiété les pas de mon côté g c'est
pas moi qui affole les populations non
seulement je la vole pas les populations
mais qui plus est il n'y a pas vraiment
de raison d'être affolés et depuis le
début parce que je vous conseille de
regarder les données de l'ined d'accord
l'ined c'est l'institut national de la
démographie fait donc venir quelqu'un de
l'ined si vous voulez et vous dire à
quelle est actuellement la perte
d'espérance de vie pas la mortalité
parce que la mortalité à 85 ans c'est
pas la mortalité des accidents de la
route
donc la perte d'espérance de vie n'est
pas la même quand vous avez une
polypathologies que vous avez un cancer
métastasé ou quand vous avez 92 ans
n'est pas la même que quand vous avez 18
ans et que vous avez un accident de moto
c'est pas la même d'accord donc ça se
calcule l'espérance de vie est la perte
d'espérance de vie actuellement calculé
pour 2020 comparé à 2019 et les deux 02
ans elle est inférieure à celle de la
perte d'espérance de vie de 2015
d'accord c'est ça à la situation donc
c'est ça c'est énorme
anxiété monstrueux c'est pas moi qui la
développe un mois et au contraire j'ai
toujours essayé d'être optimiste et au
contraire du côté de dire écoutez on
n'est pas face à un drame absolument
insupportable donc à la fin
là aussi c'est pour ça que ce n'est pas
maintenant que ça va se régler ça parte
dans un débat que ça ça glisse ça va se
régler avec les chiffres à fin et on
verra bien les chiffres et on verra bien
les chiffres donc moi je les vois
maintenant les chiffres je les suis gelé
chine manière très précise parce que ça
m'intéresse je vous dis je suis
empirique
donc ça m'intéresse de regard des
données chiffrées de les analyser les
comprend et pourquoi la grippe qui a
tellement tu es dans l'année 2015
longtemps les fichus et pourquoi et qui
a tué plus que ce que ça va tuer
installé sauf s'il se passe des choses
absolument imprévisible pour moi
pourquoi baisse et parce que d'un coup
c'était la terreur que tout le monde
attendait que qui allait arriver
c'est comme ça moi j'ai essayé là aussi
vous donner les données comparatives par
rapport au désastre du passé c'est pas
le même désir pour une simple raison
c'est que effectivement c'est pas le
même c'est pas le même âge qui meurt
donc jeudi à 50% des gens qui y sont
morts qui avait plus de 85 ans et 72 %
je crois qu'ils avaient plus de 80 ans
et donc dans les pays européens
plus de 90 % avaient plus de 60 ans donc
ce qui s'est passé c'est tous les ans
les gens qui sont sur un équilibre
précaire les les circonstances font que
et bien ces gens qui ont un équilibre
précaire donc du côté du bo et côté des
choses et donc c'est ça que nous voyons
essentiellement est là depuis les
épisodes où je vais donner tous les
morts qui sont produits depuis trois
mois sur ce ces données là voilà vous
voyez donc vous voyez les données d'âge
là chez nous je vous dis de le plus bleu
le mort le plus jeunes jusqu'à la côte
d'or avait 58 ans a malheureusement un
homme qui était dans un état absolument
épouvantable ok qu'est venue mourir qui
avait 54 ans qui a été refusée en
réanimation son état physiologique de
base était trop mauvais mais globalement
si vous voulez la perte et on n'a pas
calculé qu'il ya des calculs très
complet qui s'appelle les dalits et qui
rajoute les polypathologies à l'âge et
la perte de 2,2 d'espérance de vie va
être extrêmement mineure donc c'est pas
moi qui développe l'enquêté je les dis
encore la semaine dernière
donc c'est pas moi qui développe
l'anxiété donc le l'interdiction prix
inscrire tout le monde c'est mon opinion
dessus si vous voulez mais là encore je
vois pas comment on aurait pu avoir un
débat serein quand en espace de d'une
demi journée
on sait le ministère et le msc mis à
dire on interdit partout l'une roxy
chloroquine parce que ça tue les gens
pour un papier qui a été retiré trois
semaines après parce que c'était une
bande de pieds nickelés qui avait écrit
ce truc dont personne ne savait d'où il
sortait donc c'est à moi qui raconte des
bêtises
au bout d'un moment il faut revenir sur
terre c'est pas moi un carcan des
bêtises qu'on puisse penser qu'on puisse
avoir la pensée que ce truc est vrai
quand on parle d'un médicament qui a été
donné à deux milliards d'habitants ça
veut dire qu'au bout d'un moment on a
des connexions des deux parties de son
cerveau qui en a une qui est devenue
guerrière et symbolique
et puis l'autre qui rester pragmatique
ou pas mais c'est allé même parti
d'accord il ya quand même pour réussir à
vous faire avaler un truc comme ça il en
faut quand même je m'excuse mais tout
ceux qui ont cru un truc pareil c'est
quand même spectaculaire et pourquoi les
africains foutez de notre gueule quand
même c'est parce qu'ils sont en train de
nous dire qu'on attend tous en train de
mourir alors bois de la chloroquine j'en
bouffe et à l'âge de deux ans en afrique
on avait ça sur la table tout le monde
vous fait son comprimé plan hockey
peut-être pour ça que je crains pas la
chloroquine donc le taux attendez je
vais tout marqué après qu'est ce qui
m'amuse 1 qu'est ce qui marche pas dans
notre système de santé la hausse il faut
regarder les données chiffrées ce que je
vous suggère il ya un truc qui est très
bien fait qu'ils appellent l cette
graine ce danger qui est publié par
l'otc de tous les ans d'accord et c'est
très bien il faut regarder c'est pas moi
non plus les chiffres faut les regarder
et vous regarderez quelles sont les
différences qu'il existe entre la france
et les autres pays en termes de
mortalité en termes de d'efforts
financiers
donc il ya un effort financier
considérable de la france la france est
un des pays qui met le plus d'argent
possible dans la santé mais c'est un de
ceux qui a le moins de médecins via les
médecins les plus vieux et ça c'est
l'état qui a voulu ça la limitation par
le numerus clausus pendant trente ans
c'est pas ce gouvernement c'est l'état
qui a voulu ça donc il a limité le
nombre de médecins d'une manière
drastique
maintenant nous avons les médecins les
plus vieux d'europe ont fait partie nous
avons pas assez de médecins les médecins
hospitaliers gagnent moins d'argent
c'est pas le cas des universitaires
double salaire mais bien notre vie mais
les médecins hospitaliers sont moins
bien payés en moyenne en france que
s'ils sont payés dans les autres pays de
l'osce et des oeufs que dans la moyenne
de l'oscd eu d'accord le niveau
d'équipement en france est inférieur à
celui de la moyenne des pays de l'osce
et des eaux des grands équipements
d'accord et donc vous avez la question
vous avez la réponse moi je veux pas
débattre de sa non plus il ya les
chiffres il ya qu'à les regarder
c'est c'est
vous pouvez le télécharger sur internet
s'appelle human health and glass tous
les angles ocde publiées les données
chiffrées qui leur sont transmises comme
pour la mortalité si vous voulez savoir
la mortalité vont regarder euros moment
je suis désolé un nom un peu ridicule
s'appelle oromo c'est toutes les données
de tous les pays européens de mortalité
au fil de l'eau donc c'est suffit de les
regarder
est ce qu'il manque quelque chose sur
les mutations donc vous avez des
précisions demandées par les mutations
je viens sur des virus à tous mute tout
le temps c'est comme ça à chaque fois on
était et mutations c'est lié au fait que
vous faites une copie de quelque chose
et que vous faites une copie ya des
erreurs d'accord mais les copies de
l'adn
il ya assez peu d'erreurs en moyenne il
ya une erreur par millions de copies
donc sur un million de base
tgc dans la 1 million qui présentent une
mutation dans nos génome dans ceux des
bactéries la rn là c'est un virus à arn
il ya cent fois plus de mutations une
pour 10000 à peu près pour une pour 20
minutes 30 mx a été estimé ces estimés
en général et pour ce virus là ce estimé
être un pur donc ces mutations l'a
parfois sont des mutations dont on voit
pas qu'on appelle synonyme c'est-à-dire
qu'elle n'entraîne pas un changement
d'acides aminés ce qui ne veut pas dire
qu'elle ne change pas des domaines de la
science actuelle c'est que parfois ça
change pas d'acides aminés mais ça
change la soie appelle la fitness et la
capacité de se multiplier du virus
parfois ça change un incident les
mutations qu'on a observé il y en a
quelques unes qui se trouve dans la
protéine spike dont vous avez beaucoup
entendu parler et qui est une des
molécules qui fermement la spécificité
de ces gros navires us il ya des ddd
mutation qui se trouve dans la
nucléocapside c'est à dire dans le
premier anti essais les deux grands
antigènes si vous voulez que nous
reconnaissons quand on a une réponse
immunitaire c'est un la numéro unités au
gap sic mais qui est qui et qui a
beaucoup de points communs avec tous les
autres coronavirus c'est pour ça qu'il
ya des réactions croisées peut-être dé
protection croisée
et puis la protéine spike qui est
relativement spécifiques
là aussi tentant dans lequel on a une
mutation donc ce que nous ont conté ce
qu'on regarde
et le nombre de mutations qui sont
survenues par rapport à virus souche
d'accord donc bien sûr il ya des
mutations mais globalement on avait
l'habitude qui est en moyenne 9 à 10
mutation par rapport au virus souche
pendant la première partie c'est à dire
qu'ils allaient dans les souches que
nous avons eu entre mars et mai d'accord
dans cette deuxième partie le nombre de
mutations par souche par rapport à la
mutation mer par rapport à la souche
mère est dix fois plus grande il ya
beaucoup plus de mutations que ce que
nous envoyons avant et ça il ya
plusieurs clones qui sont comme ça
qu'ils ont donc une distance on mesure
la distance en regardant le nombre de
mutations par rapport à la souche
primaires si vous voulez donc ça veut
dire que la distance par rapport à ceux
exprimés avec plus importante maintenant
que ce qu'elle était avant merci pour
ces précisions va continuer et si on
d'être concis dans les questions et les
réponses néanmoins il ya une réponse que
vous n'avez pas fait c'est concernant
les préconisations du comité
scientifique qui n'était pas suivie par
le gouvernement si vous avez en quelques
mots quelque chose à dire pour répondre
à roger karoutchi
je me suis plus qu'elle était il ya il
ya eu déjà eu quelques recommandations
qui n'ont pas été suivis on l'avait vu
au moment des écoles on l'a vu encore
dernièrement où il
la question est extrêmement sa mesure le
conseil scientifique affirme enfin firme
est normalement l'autorité de référence
qui donne des avis parfois le
gouvernement suive parfois le
gouvernement ne suis pas est ce que
aujourd'hui l'existence du conseil
scientifique a encore une vraie valeur
dans le débat rapidement je suis
d'accord pour le fait que le
gouvernement décide de suivre tu as su
parce que la responsabilité politique
nous on voit bien responsabilités
politiques
donc la responsabilité politique c'est
la responsabilité politique c'est la
responsabilité politique c'est celui qui
a la responsabilité qui décide c'est
comme ça que j'aurais chose après il a
des conseils que ces conseils soient
personnellement je n'étais pas d'avis
que les conseils du conseil scientifique
soit publique
je pense qu'ils auraient dû avoir un
conseil du président ou un conseil des
ministres que ça se décide au tour des
ministres et que le ministre disent
écoutez voilà j'ai écouté voilà mon
opinion est que chaud sorti comme ça
c'était mon avis et jusqu'à présent
c'est toujours comme ça que ça s'est
passé mais la composition du conseil
dans une partie qui était stratégique
à mon sens n'était pas bonne parce que
c'était le dérivé de reacting qui était
le groupe qui a été mis en place par les
termes ça c'est mon opinion
alors on y va toujours le plus court
possible il nous reste un bon quart
d'heure petit quart d'heure
angèle préville merci monsieur le
président donc mon professeur j'ai
d'abord une question qui vient à la
suite de ce que vous venez de vous dire
sur la mutation du virus donc il y à des
mutations mais je pense que dans
l'inconscient collectif
on parle de mutation quand le virus
devient beaucoup plus dangereux pas on
sous-entend que alors est ce que dans
tous ces mutations est ce que dans l'eau
cure les occurrences vous voyez arriver
par les connaissances que vous avez qu à
un moment donné il risque de devenir
beaucoup plus virulent c'est à dire
beaucoup plus dangereux la deuxième
question alors sur les essais alors vous
avez évoqué les raisons éthiques voire
morale qui font que vous n'avez pas
voulu avoir recours à des placebos parce
qu'on était en k2 dans une période de
crise avec une maladie très grave
puisqu'elle peut provoquer des décès
alors est ce que il vous semble est ce
qu'il ya des choses là dessus sur le
fait que quand on est en crise
on fait pas de décès
visiblement parce que effectivement les
arguments que vous avez peuvent
s'entendre
et puis parce que on a souvent dit que
l'effet placebo c'est l homéopathie et
cetera donc pour des choses pour des de
la petite bobologie peut-être alors
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous dire sur
l'effet placebo parce que peut-être ce
serait intéressant de savoir après une
autre question
vous avez évoqué la création de centres
anti infectieux est ce que votre est-ce
que vous sous-entendez que votre
structure à marseille en est une est ce
qu'il y manque quelque chose
est-ce qu'il y en a d'autres sur le
territoire est ce qu'il ya des
équivalents ailleurs et est ce que vous
avez entendre été entendus par les
pouvoirs publics pour pouvoir après la
crise
développer des centres comme le vôtre je
remercie gilles guillotin
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le professeur avant toute chose je
voudrais quand même exprimé un regret
effectivement de ne pas pouvoir avoir
avoir été auditionnée sur un système de
tables rondes et je me suis exprimé
auprès du président je pense que ça
aurait été à mon sens plus éclairant
puisque vous êtes un scientifique qui
parle à des scientifiques et ça nous
aurait permis de peut-être d'avoir eu
des idées un peu plus clair ensuite je
voudrais rebondir sur le tout début de
vos propos vous avez exprimé le fait de
dire je ne comprends pas je comprends
pas ce qui s'est passé pourquoi ça s'est
emballée médiatiquement quand j'ai parlé
etc
c'est ce que vous avez dit au début de
vos propos liminaire c'est ça que je
parte pas voilà moi je voudrais vous
dire que je vais vous donner mon
expérience personnelle je vous dire que
je pense comprendre
moi je n'ai pas compris par contre le
premier matin ou en fait vous êtes
intervenu sur les ondes nom de radio où
vous avez affirmé à ce moment là
effectivement l'effet positif de la
chloroquine et avoir suscité un espoir
en fait important chez des habitants des
français qui étaient à ce moment-là
inquiet en pleine période d'épidémie est
dans une situation
c'est une situation quasi catastrophique
dans notre pays donc votre en fait votre
expression publique de votre statut de
chercheur reconnu et de renom a
effectivement suscité
un grand espoir or ne pensez vous pas
qu'à ce moment là alors vous n'êtes ni
journaliste ni politique vous êtes
vraiment un scientifique que l'on écoute
reconnu et sur lequel on pose en fait
nos oreilles et notre conviction
ne pensez vous pas que vos paroles à ce
moment là n'aurait pas dû ted être
peut-être différé est ce que vous pensez
pas que les études auraient dû être un
peu plus avancé des résultats plus
concrets avant avant de douala d'aller
confirmer ou infirmer des choses comme
ça qui ont été prises chez une partie de
nos concitoyens comme d'un peu d'argent
comptant et je pense que ça a été le
début de la fracture d'opinion dans
notre pays est un espèce de clan en fait
dans ce pays les pour et les contre le
professeur à août alors que le débat et
je le conçois n'est absolument pas là
donc c'est un petit peu voilà est-ce
qu'il ya pas une forme d' imprudence ou
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous pensé que
c'était la bonne solution et que vous
recommenceriez avec l'expérience ce même
cette même expression publique et après
j'avais deux autres questions mais ça a
été répondu pourquoi ne pas avoir fait
les études en double aveugle mais ça
rejoint la première est enfin là que la
question de la mutation est ce que la
mutation que vous exprimer en
laboratoire est une mutation clinique
avec plus grand plus de gravité ou au
contraire une gravité moins importante
et puis un changement de cible voilà
mais la question était posée donc je
n'irai pas plus loin je vous remercie
merci merci céline boulay merci mais
c'est le président j'étais vraiment venu
à cette audition m'a aussi pour poser la
question qui rejoint celle de steve hay
et vernouillet de ma collègue alain
stands qui était de dire que dit de vous
finalement cette sur médiatisation et
cet emballement médiatique
et qu'est ce que ça dit du débat
contradictoire en france et de la
démocratie sanitaire alors vous avez
partiellement répondu et notamment
répondu avec une certaine modestie je le
trouve en tout cas personnellement tout
au long de cette audition en faisant
l'apologie de l'empirisme et en disant
on attend un peu on va comparer les
chiffres et là on verra qui aura raison
il vous avait parlé de pionnier en la
matière en tout cas puisqu'il s'agit
souvent hors de nos auditions de retour
d'expérience je note qu'il ya une grande
confusion qui règne dans la tête de nos
compatriotes français puisque en
attendant les chiffres est de savoir qui
aura raison le retour d'expérience qui
était censée rassurer tout le monde en
disant on n'avait qu'une
la crise majeure on saura qui on saura
gérer un deuxième rebond pour l'instant
créer cette confusion est peut-être
cette inquiétude et on le voit quand on
interroge sur la mutation du virus en
fait on a des réponses qui sont
totalement contradictoires
donc moi j'ai maintenant 3 toute petite
question précise la première on a
beaucoup parlé donc de mutation du virus
mais est ce que vous seriez nous dire où
en est l'état de nos connaissances quant
aux malades qui ont été symptomatique
vous disiez très justement qu'au début
il y avait peu de faire de dano semis et
d'agouazi il y en a eu beaucoup plus
après est ce que ces malades là peut
avoir une évolution de leurs séquelles
par exemple atteint avis ou durablement
dans leur père danos me aggasy ça c'est
une première car la deuxième je ne crois
pas que vous ayez répondu à notre
collègue rapporteur bernard jomier quand
vous avez dit de manière très forte dans
matière infectieuses il y avait une
destruction physique de l'organisation
des maladies infectieuses qui est à
l'origine de cette d'esprit des
instructions et pourquoi
enfin rapide lorsque vous aviez été
interrogé récemment pour savoir ce que
vous pensiez du port du masque
généralisée vous l'avez répondu je ne
fais pas de politique
et vous avez une phrase tout à l'heure
que j'ai trouvé forte aussi en dix ans
et l'intendance qui suit la décision
or on en a parlé ce matin avec le comité
scientifique on a eu l'impression qu'au
début il y avait pas de port du masque
généralisée parce qu'il y avait pas de
masque maintenant il l'est parce qu'on
est des masques et je voulais savoir ce
que vous pensiez de ça je vous remercie
olivier paccaud merci monsieur le
président professeur ce matin
effectivement les membres du conseil
scientifique comme l'a dit olivier henno
ont évoqué l'impréparation de notre
système médical pour faire face vous
même
ça vient d'être redit dans votre propos
liminaire vous avez pointé du doigt la
désorganisation voire la déstructuration
programmée entre guillemets de du
système de recherche épidémiologique de
recherche
est ce qu'en fait c'est pas plutôt une
combinaison des deux qui a abouti à ce
que l'on peut considérer quand même
comme une hécatombe alors les chiffres
sont plus ou moins variable
vous avez dit vous même tout à l'heure
que c'était peut-être pas si dramatique
que ça par rapport à aux résultats 2015
de la grippe de 2015
je suis pas sûr que ça ne soit pas
dramatique quand même par contre ma
question elle va traiter de vous avez
évoqué le benchmarking les résultats
français sont loin d'être brillant il ya
pire
il ya mieux ce matin on avait eu
quelques cas de l'allemagne a quand même
dix mille morts mais il y a quelques
jours dans cette même dans ce même
hémicycle nous avons reçu les
ambassadeurs de corée du sud de taïwan
et on a eu des chiffres qui sont tout à
fait éloquent sept morts à taïwan 346 en
corée du sud
alors ma question c'est on a vu ce
qu'ils ont fait eux vous d'après vous
quand on veut éteindre un incendie
épidémiologique éviter qu'ils se
transforment en brasier
qu'est ce que l'on doit faire
immédiatement quand on a pas de vaccin
si monsieur le président à barisis merci
mais simplement de questions vous avez
dit tout à l'heure c'est le temps qui
fait le tri et vous avez cité beaucoup
de papier c'est vrai que vis-à-vis nous
déjà mais je pense les français c'est
difficile quand même à comprendre parce
qu'on sait qu'il ya des papiers et vous
en avez d'ailleurs vous l'avez dénonce
et qui sont malheureusement publiés et
qu'ils sont faux et je pense que la
confusion dont pas se parler ma collègue
quand même extrêmement importante et que
même s'il faut attendre le temps c'est
vrai que la science a quand même parlé
sur un certain nombre de choses et comme
bernard jomier et d'autres moi je
regrette qu'il n'y ait pas de
confrontation parce que comme on n'a pas
de confrontation entre chercheurs
on vous voit dans les médias les uns se
re pour les autres contre et c'est vrai
que ce matin on parlait peut-être au
lieu du conseil scientifique est
peut-être une agence dédiée aux crises
et pas seulement d'ailleurs avec des
scientifiques mais aussi avec des
chercheurs des sciences humaines et
sociales
et s'il y avait peut-être cette agence
en france peut-être que ça permettrait
aussi aux français de mieux comprendre
de moins avoir peur et je voudrais avoir
un peu votre avis là dessus et puis la
dernière
la deuxième question ça rejoint
d'ailleurs mon collègue david assouline
c'est on n'a pas parlé du vaccin
quelle est votre position aujourd'hui
sur le vaccin merci david assouline où
la question est posée par je lui ai
soufflé une question qui me venait à
l'esprit mais non j'ai deux questions
brèves
la première c'est je reste perplexe
parce que finalement la polémique qui a
fait connaître au grand public
votre non monsieur le professeur vous
étiez déjà très connue des milieux qui
devait l'être qui était professionnel
c'est votre traitement
je ne comprends pas que six mois après
on en reste à
il ya les pour et les contre moi je pose
la question
six mois après même quand ça n'a pas été
autorisé à la prescription
je connais du monde qui parce qu'il n'y
avait pas de traitement se sont rués est
une façon ou d'une autre vers ce
médicament il n'y a pas eu de résultats
aujourd'hui on ne vous avez fait vos
hôtes est sur une centaine de personnes
vous défendez qu' il y avait des
améliorations mais maintenant six mois
après c'est plus un débat il ya rien de
probant enfin je comprends pas ou sinon
qu'est ce que vous dites à monsieur
macron vous lui dites que il interdit et
à tous ces scientifiques à tous ces gens
notamment le comité scientifique qui
disent que ce n'est pas efficace faut
aller au bout
vous les accusez de refuser un
médicament qui empêcherait des cas de
s'aggraver de soigner des français c'est
ça six mois après c'est pas un débat des
pour et des contres moi j'ai beaucoup de
critiques je suis critique comme tout le
monde
donc je prends pas
bob pas tout ce que nous dit le
gouvernement les gens les scientifiques
mais là à moins de me dire tiens coupe
l'eau qu'on veut que des français ne se
soigne pas et meurt je ne comprend pas
la nature du débat et ma conclusion en
question parce que la seule façon pour
moi de le comprendre c'est que derrière
le scientifique que vous êtes est le
pragmatique que vous êtes
il ya peut-être quelque chose qui vient
troubler c'est l'idéologie
qu'avez-vous de commun pour faire
tribune commune bientôt avec monsieur
onfray philosophe
qu'avez-vous de commun à dire ou sur la
pandémie ou sur la société
je ne comprends pas merci jean sol
excusez moi monsieur le président
monsieur le professeur
j'ai plusieurs questions comme
l'ensemble des français j'ai été
confinés que pensez-vous du confinement
total mis en place dans notre pays
aurait-il pu être évité à l'instar
d'autres pays qui nous ont présenté
récemment leurs résultats quel est votre
avis sur la doctrine en matière de
masques qui s'est fait à géométrie
variable faut-il le reconnaître qui est
encore floue aujourd'hui et dont
certains remettent en cause le degré de
filtration dans certains contextes
pensez vous que les moyens en matière de
recherche sont au rendez vous en france
je ne pense pas vous ne l'aviez déjà
exprimé lorsque nous vous nous avions
auditionnés vous savez cité l'exemple
tout à l'heure du nombre de scanners et
enfin est il possible selon vous de
raccourcir les délais pour réaliser les
tests aujourd'hui et surtout pour un
obtenir les résultats dans un délai
raisonnable merci merci vais écouter dix
minutes 10 minutes pour tout ça donc
s'il vous plaît le premier point qui est
qu'elle sur place et volet sport vous
savez c'est un vrai point c'est une
occasion que je puisse discuter qu'elle
confesse j'ai discuté aussi que bernard
henri lévy de de dire que c'est
dramatique d'apporter de l'espoir
je suis pas d'accord avec vous je pense
est dramatique d'apporter du désespoir
je pensais je continue à le penser je
continuerai à le porter jusqu'à toi et
l'effet placebo c'est effectivement
d'abord ça commence par apporter
l'espoir
donc il ya eu négligence de la
connaissance de l'effet placebo
scientifiques les terrifiantes
l'effet placebo c'est un effet
biologique que l'on peut parfaitement
noté avec les moyens actuels de
radiologie qui permet de voir qu'il ya
des zones qui sont éteintes ou qui sont
ali mais quand on vous savez quand on
vous dit aux gens qu'ils vont mourir on
voit les zones certaines dans le cerveau
ça s'appelle l'effet nocebo et donc
quand on dit ça tous les soirs à la
télévision ce qu'on fait on crée de
l'effet nocebo qui est visible
radiologiquement quand on donne de
l'espoir aux gens aient compris avec
l'effet placebo on voit les zones où ça
se fixe
et sa 6e problème en droit commun zodiac
et paix intérieure ça calme les gens
donc ça je m'excuse et de la science
encore la deuxième chose c'est que
effectivement me souviens plus qui pose
la question mais on peut rebondir dessus
il ya une vraie question sur les
séquelles malheureusement on a commencé
à travailler dessus on a fait un papier
dessus qui est très impressionnant qui
montre que les zones il ya des zones qui
ont un hypométabolisme derrière le bulbe
olfactif qui semble persister on sait
pas combien de temps elles vont
persister on sait pas ce qu'il guérira
et on sait pas ce qu'ils en protège mais
oui il ya des séquelles cérébrales
pendant un certain temps je sais pas
combien de temps plus que de séquelles
pulmonaires que l'on redoutait beaucoup
redoutaient beaucoup qui a beaucoup de
fibres hozjan a relativement peu mais il
y à des extinctions du métabolisme
cérébral qui qu'on perçoit et on n'a pas
suffisamment de recul pour savoir
combien de temps ça va durer
le lead et j'y peux rien je vous leur
direz vous pensez vraiment que le
l'histoire de hydroxyque eurokin si vous
voulez et l'histoire de ce débat est un
débat franco français avec moi au milieu
et c'est parfait c'est simplement pas
vrai vous voyez ça dit si c'est vrai
c'est un débat mondial
vous vous rendez bien compte qu'on
comment vous pouvez penser qu'une bande
de polichinelle a publiée dans le new
england journal médecine et dans land 7
si on était pas on n'avait pas perdu
toute notion de base pour publier des
choses pareilles qui ont été rétractées
dans les trois mois je n'ai jamais vu ça
de toute l'histoire le métier j'ai
jamais vu ça c'est pas moi qui ai fait
ça c'est pas moi qui ai déterminer sa
donc arretez de croire c'est une
histoire franco-française est un
phénomène beaucoup plus puissants que ça
qui est extrêmement qui est
international qui touche
il ya une partie qui a réagi d'une
certaine manière qui est l'europe de
l'ouest et une partie des états unis qui
a d'ailleurs les plus mauvais chiffres
mondiaux de gestion de la crise qui a
géré d'une certaine manière en courant
après deux molécules nouvelles fait à
nouveau par des laboratoires qui
maintenant cours d'une certaine entre
manière après après la vaccination il ya
une autre partie qui était une partie de
gestion extrêmement pragmatique y
compris si vous avez vu les coréens
c'est un pragmatisme qui est totale donc
il y as we une manière pragmatique de
gérer chose qui est de détecter 10
et il ya des gens qui a des pays
auxquels on a réquisitionné des hôtels
pour y mettre les gens qui étaient
positifs tant qu'il était positif de
manière à faire ce qu'on faisait avant
avec le lazaret et non pas faire ce
qu'on a fait avec le confinement qui est
la quarantaine
donc c'est des natures différentes ce
qui s'est passé dans la destruction et
la direction je suis d'accord que ça n'a
pas été volontaire il s'est trouvé que
il ya eu une époque qui est une époque
paradoxale qui était juste avant
l'épidémie de sida les gens disaient
maladies infectieuses c'est terminé donc
il y avait à paris à l'hôpital claude
bernard les gens ont travaillé sur les
maladies infectieuses et assez et de
manière assez extraordinaire c'est au
moment où le sida est arrivé on a fermé
claude d'art
c'est en effet fermer l'endroit dans
lequel on pouvait investir massivement
pour pouvoir lutter contre les nouvelles
épidémies qui arrive et ça a été la pire
épidémie du 20e siècle la sueur et donc
il ya une vraie il ya une vraie question
de remise en cause est ce que vous vous
considérez comme est incompréhensible
moi je comprends bien c'est que quand
les gens ont pris prochains mois y
compris d'ailleurs ont pris une
direction c'est très très difficile de
sortir du sentier dans lequel on est
rentré c'est très compliqué de dire
écoutez on s'est trompé finalement c'est
pas comme ça qu'il fallait faire c'est
compliqué pour chacun d'entre nous mais
c'est compliqué pour le ministre c'est
compliqué pour le président la
république c'est compliqué pour
delfraissy et ses prolongements
compliqué pour moi même si je suis pas
lucide de ce point de vue là parce que
je ne vois pas donc cesser c'est pas
encore une fois c'est ce qui s'est passé
et quand vous me dites et détient
comment ça se traduit moi je le trouve
étonnant que ce soit que les consignes
de maladies infectieuses dans
l'assistance publique de paris soit
donnée par le directeur sens unique de
paris marseille les consignes de
maladies physiques ne sont pas donnés
par le dg de cette ligue marseille et je
peux vous dire que quand j'étais jeune
titulaire de chaire défectueuse c'est
lui qui disent il ajouté ça qu'il faut
faire
c'était pas le dg de paris c'est étrange
non enfin j'en sais rien c'est un truc
de professionnels la médecine je
m'excuse donc il y a
question moi je dis c'est ce que je
pense je pensais moi je pensais qu'ils
valent et permana fixot paul necker
pasteur je les écris en 2003 ça mettait
à necker à pasteur faire un bâtiment
pour les maladies infectieuses à necker
soit juste à côté de pasteur que les
gens travaillent c'est une antenne de la
nds et maintenant santé publique et là
il y aurait quelque chose qui pourrait
avoir une taille mondiale où on y aurait
des interlocuteurs soient capables de
tout faire ça c'était raisonnable
c'est ce que je pense et l époque je
pense encore maintenant peut-être parce
que je suis incapable de changer d'avis
là c'est possible est ce que j'ai oublié
quelque chose vous posez la question de
dudu du confinement et du masque cetc
des questions sur le qui sont
extrêmement ok il est extrêmement
difficile de répondre
il ya des gens qui commencent à étudier
ça à faire des études comparatives et
même ses études comparatives elles sont
difficiles à analyser parce que les
comportements sociaux dans les
différents pays sont pas les mêmes donc
le comportement social en italie et en
suède sait pas exactement même en
particulier dans l'est les contacts
sociaux sont pas les mêmes et donc de
comparer l'effet du confinement sur
l'efficacité des mesures c'est quelque
chose qui est très complexe et moi je
pensais donc c'est ce que j'ai dit quand
j'ai rencontré le président je le dis
moi il faut prendre je pense que le rôle
du politique c'est de prendre toutes les
mesures pour éviter l'affolement la peur
la peur est terrible il faut éviter
l'affolement mais si ça donne l'effet
inverse si vous voyez alors c'est pas
fonctionnel parce que le confinement ça
ça a été analysé en italie en espagne
sur des milliers de tests de donneurs de
sang 1
le confinement n'a pas protégé les gens
individuellement du risque d'infection
c'est à dire que les gens qui n'étaient
pas pour des raisons professionnelles à
part le métier de santé qui n'était pas
confinée tu es plutôt moins positif que
les gens qu'on finit donc ya pas de
substrats scientifique individuel ce qui
ne veut pas dire que ce ne soit pas un
choix de société un moment donné de dire
écoutez plutôt que tout le monde soit
folle et s'inquiète émigrent si vous
voulez il vaut mieux les confiner donc
je sais pas répondre à ça et pour le
masquer
c'est pareil c'est pas une vérité
scientifique brutale il ya une vérité
scientifique brutale c'est
quand vous êtes dans le personnel de
soins canton étant donné qu'on est à 30
40 centimètres des gens le risque de
contamination est plus important c'est
évident ça a été il a été démontré que
le masque de diminuer dans ces
conditions dans les autres conditions ça
n'a pas été démontrée ça peut pas l'être
donc c'est une question là aussi de
message social est-ce que ce message
social est utile j'ai pas d'avis que
j'irais plutôt oui si vous voulez je
sais pas s'il faut être extrêmement
punitifs sur quelque chose comme ça mais
je dirais que de le fait de porter un
masque si ça empêche les gens de
s'embrasser et quand ils voient ou si ça
leur permet de se faire se rappeler
qu'il ya quelque chose qui circule c'est
c'est pas on peut penser que c'est
raisonnable
voilà donc deux de permettre de
conserver une distance sociale sans se
faire d'énormes illusions sur le pouvoir
c'est les mains elle veut faire
attention il faut passer dix fois vingt
fois l'alcool sur les mains par jour ça
c'est vraiment c'est les mains qui sont
la clé mais si ce message là permet de
changer les comportements
pendant cette période là je pense que
c'est intérieur et quant aux mutations
jour accéder à des questions
huit ans je m'excuse si mi temps dans
votre dans votre esprit ça veut dire
plus méchant jeu j'avais dit que c'était
plus méchant un débutant ça veut dire
que ça change
on a plutôt l'impression que les mutants
vont à sonder forme dégradée de la forme
initiale
c'est plutôt notre impression qu'on
serait c'est très compliqué de deviner
le pouvoir pathogène d'un virus en
voyant sa séquence personnes
certainement faire mais globalement nous
c'est ce ca 12 appareils plutôt lié à
des formes qui sont bien sûr aussi sûr
les une régulation un peu de la parole
scientifique jeu mais mais mais mais
encore une fois ce jeu m'a plu et le
france mais mes jeux d'abord je vous
appartient pas c'est à dire que ma
parole scientifique d'une parole libre
qui est garantie par la constitution et
par l'histoire de ce pays et elle
s'adresse à une quantité de gens dans le
monde
vous pensez que ce que j'ai dit a pas eu
de conséquence seule la la prescription
de dix ans que l'origine des hits robin
vous vous trompez très très lourdement
il ya un institut de sondage qui sont de
tous les médecins du monde pour leur
savoir quels sont pour leur demander
quels sont les médicaments qu'ils
prescrivent dans le coffee
vous allez dire que ça il ya une une
influence sur la thérapeutique nombre de
gens considèrent que c'est une
thérapeutique essentiels qui était qui
est énorme
vous verrez bien avec le temps pour
l'instant encore une fois c'est pas moi
qui racontait les balivernes sur la sur
la toxicité d'un médicament est prescrit
chez deux milliards de personnes ne vous
raconte pas de balivernes
on verra bien vous verrez bien pour
l'instant c'est les dossiers et les les
publications sur l'usagé hydroxy clan
qui ne demandent que ça ça diminue en 30
et 50 % la mortalité sont en train de
s'accumuler
vous verrez bien vous n'êtes pas de
sortir une en sortent tous les jours
vous verrez c'est ce qui concerne la
question de jean sol oui il manque de
scanners notamment l'osu l'avait dit et
on le partage on a déjà eu l'occasion
catherine déroché temps particulièrement
attentives à ce sujet là d'en parler
lors notamment des préfets cesse quant
aux délais de test effectivement on
constate que iad et nous on en parle de
stratégie devrait peut-être évoluer
écoutez nous on n'a pas de problème de
délai de test le délai moyen de rendu
chez nous ces huit heures il n'y a pas
de tests qui se sont rendus en plus de
24 heures pardon c'est qu'ils ont des
machines en effet qui ont des résultats
très rapides mais tout le monde ne les a
pas les laboratoires d'analysés auquel
le lambda dans lequel on va n'a pas ce
type de machine mais je m'excuse mais
globalement pour pau pour clore puisque
c'est une question qui m'a été posée
c'est pourquoi finalement ces approches
ne se réconcilie pas des gens à venir
voir ce qu'on fait enfin des salons à
tester 79 personnes à venir voir ce
qu'on fait je vous signale quand le
ministre est passé à marseille il n'est
même pas venu donc c'est pas moi qui me
fait rire personne et en particulier je
suis républicain donc je respecte les
gens qui sont aux affaires je vous dis
encore une fois nous je publiais shift
ce que nous faisons régulièrement et
toutes les semaines écoutez ça s'appelle
le benchmarking ça aussi si vous savoir
comment on fait il faut venir voir
je refuse personne donc à partie deux
personnes ça m'est égal et quant à
discuter avec les ans je discute avec
tous les gens intelligents quel que soit
leur bord
merci merci bien écoutez on va clore ce
débat en attendant le suivant en vous
remerciant ya pas eu de confrontation
mais il ya eu des échanges frontaux ce
qui était important merci